Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Mensch Lilos, SAP, Telekom und Bundesregierung haben eine Wahnapp veröffentlicht und du hast nicht davor gewarnt.
Ja, also das war echt lustig, da waren irgendwie kurzfristig zweitausendachthundertsiebzehn Aktienoptionen im Angebot. Ich glaube, es war ein Fehler.
Lokbuch, Netzpolitik, Nummer dreihundertfünfzig, Linus. Dreihundertfünfzig, vom siebzehnten, siebzehnten, siebzehnten Juni, zwanzig zwanzig.
Siebzehn bis siebzehnter sech.
Genau, ein ein Tag nach Corona ab.
Ja
Die neue Zeitrechnung. Jetzt werden wir alle ausgeforscht. Ja ja, von wegen.
Äh wir hatten doch in der letzten Sendung noch äh Geräte mit der Zeitrechnung, ne? Ähm.
Ähm Ano Domini und so weiter und das ist ganz einfach, äh wurde ich dann auch korrigiert, die Zeitrechnung ist eigentlich ne, in amerikanischen, ganz einfach äh BC und AC,
wie vor Chorona in After Corona, ja, ganz muss man gar nicht in den, in den lateinischen Bereich gehen.
Aber das bezieht sich dann, glaube ich, dann doch eher auf den ersten Januar nicht so sehr auf den sechzehnten Juni. Aber auf den sechzehnten Juni gehen wir heute ein bisschen mehr ein.
Und was jetzt mit deinen Aktienoptionen.
Ja, keine Ahnung, der Abenteuer wollte die ja dann doch nicht mehr haben. Ähm nee, ich fahre.
Der war wahrscheinlich zu jung dafür.
Also, das ist ja kein Thementhema der Netzpolitik, aber ich würde trotzdem gerne ganz kurz ganz vorsichtig anmerken, ne?
Dass ich, dass es mich schüttelt, wenn ich lese
der Antwortstünde unter Lobbyismusverdacht. Das nennt sich nicht Lobby, es muss das nennt sich Korruption. Und wenn er behauptet, er wäre nicht käuflich, dann frage ich mich, warum er denn dann seine Aktienoption zurückgegeben hat. Er war doch nicht käuflich. Er hat jedoch gar nicht für eine Gegenleistung bekommen, dass er mit Bundestagsbriefpapier
irgendwie bei der Bundesregierung sich für ein Unternehmen einsetzt, an dem er danach beteiligt wird. Also ist das äh das ist so,
Hm? Da sieht man, der Typ ist wirklich durch und durch CDU, ne? Das ist äh der schnell gelernte junge Christ.
Aber aber Linas, der ist doch erst siebenundzwanzig, dann da gilt doch quasi noch Welpenschutz.
Der muss sich doch erstmal noch ein Vermögen aufbauen.
Ja. Also da kann man doch nicht alle Tricks drauf haben.
Alter ist der doch offenbar hatte. Ja also na ja den einen trägt den er nicht drauf hat ist sicher halt einfach nicht erwischen zu lassen ne.
Ja. Sollte sich mal ein Vortrag über Obst anschauen. Hast du doch nicht was im Angebot?
Nee, also Schwarz-Gelb-Zahlungen und Korruptionen gehört einfach nicht zu meinem äh Expertisebereich, aber ähm,
könnte im Laufe der Sendung habe ich dann doch noch eine kleine Obsecmpfehlung, die interessanterweise tatsächlich erneut, ja, ähm jemand einen Fehler gemacht, den ähm,
den Thorsten und ich zumindest in diesem Obstex-Vortrag mit erwähnt haben, dass man ähm.
Dass man in, dass man dass dieser Architektur, die dort verwendet wurde, eben Risikoreich ist. Aber okay. Tim, ich möchte eine Sendung empfehlen.
Ja, mach mal.
Du darf ich ja nur, weil weil du weißt welche. Ähm.
Gab's auch sonst ihn dann empfehlen?
Im Podcast UKW, wo Timja regelmäßig ähm mit Pavel Meier über die,
Corona, Situation in Deutschland, sprich im Corona Wikley, äh hatte er jetzt auch am Montag ähm schon zu Gast zwei.
Personen aus dem SAP, Entwicklerteam für die Corona Warn-App, die dort, ich glaube, es war anderthalb Stunden oder war das sogar.
Zweieinhalb Stunden.
Zweieinhalb Stunden, ja? Sehr ausführliches äh Gespräch führen. Und ich finde auch, also ne so diesen guten.
Äh Niveau, einerseits da sitzen halt äh Experte, Experten, die sich mit dem Thema auseinandergesetzt haben, die es selber geschrieben haben und haben ein Moderator, der ihnen dabei,
gar nicht so viel helfen muss, diese Debatte auch noch auf den Allgemeinverständlichen Niveau zu führen und das denke ich ist eine, der eine der wichtigen.
Aufklärungsquellen für Menschen, die jetzt vor der Entscheidung stehen, ob sie diese App nutzen möchten oder nicht. Und das denke ich, ist da enorm gut gelungen und ist ein sehr, sehr interessanter Einblick, deswegen würde ich das empfehlen, weil,
ja klar ist, dass ähm ich schon,
vor Monaten hier auch angekündigt habe, dass ich nicht diese App empfehlen werde, weil ich möchte, dass jede Person
ähm eine eigene informierte Entscheidung trifft und dabei finde ich ist diese Sendung eine der der wichtigen Ressourcen.
Ja, das ist wirklich ganz gut gelaufen. Kann man, kann man so sagen, es war sehr angenehmes äh.
Sprechen, da kam eigentlich auch irgendwie nahezu alles zur Sprache, was äh zur Sprache kommen konnte,
So, da sind natürlich die Perspektive des SAP-Teams hatten, waren jetzt so Details, wie es grad so bei der Telekom gelaufen ist, natürlich nicht so vertreten, aber.
Denke, man hat auch gemerkt, dass.
Wir mittlerweile äh glaube ich auch an so einem Punkt angekommen sind, wo in den Unternehmen, die wir mal so ein bisschen.
Leichtfertig auch so als Digitalverweigerer äh verschreien. Gut, dass kann man jetzt SAP selber jetzt konkret vielleicht nicht ganz so vorwerfen, ne, aber auch so was so die Digitalkultur betrifft, insbesondere Open Source.
Die haben die, die haben diese Tankerkultur wie unterstellt man den da doch noch? Ne, Öltankerkultur, ne? Wenn der, wenn du möchtest, dass das Schiff in in sieben Jahren äh eine Rechtskurve fährt, musst du jetzt anfangen äh an an dem, an dem Lenkrad zu drehen, ne?
Ja, ich kenne was ich habe irgendwann mal so eine schöne Late Nights Geschichte gehört, wo so einer erzählt so, ja, er werde in der Bar und da saß dann immer,
immer wenn er da war, saß er dieser dicke Typ an der Bar und hat sich irgendwie überhaupt nicht,
bewegt, mit niemandem geredet, immer nur an seinem Dring rumgelutscht und so weiter und hat sich immer gefragt, was ist mit dem eigentlich
und dann gab's irgendwann mal so eine Schlägerei und jemand äh
ordentlich hauer abbekommen hat, äh der es nicht verdient hatte und dann ist der Typ auf einmal aufgestanden, hat sich irgendwie diese Typen vorgenommen und wie aus diesem Laden rausgeprügelt auf eine Art und Weise, wie es nie für möglich gehalten hätte und er dachte sich noch
wow das und so ein bisschen ist das manchmal auch bei so,
großen Unternehmen, dass man sich dann doch irgendwie wundert, so, ah, okay, da ist dann also durchaus nochmal ein bisschen äh Potential,
was man so nicht gedacht hat, ne? Aber es konnte diesem Gespräch auch ganz gut rüber.
Dass dass das eben auch so so ein schrittweiser, kultureller Wandel ist und das auch im Rahmen dieses Projektes,
wieder da weitere Schritte äh gegangen werden. Mussten und dann auch gegangen wurden.
Ich habe in den letzten zwei Tagen, glaube ich, ähm sehr viele.
Tausend der tausend Male nicht, aber sehr viel of sehr viel häufig mich wiederholen müssen zu dieser Chorona-App und äh ich würde hier in dieser Sendung nochmal so ganz kurz ein paar häufig gestellte Fragen dazu ähm
beantworten, wollen einfach, damit wir das hier auch gemacht haben. Ähm einiges davon ist vielleicht auch für.
Unsere Hörerinnen, eine Wiederholung, ja, weil wir das vielleicht vor zwei Monaten schon mal besprochen haben oder vor zwei Wochen, deswegen versuchen wir das jetzt so ein bisschen kurz zu halten.
Und äh nochmal so die wichtigsten Fragen zu beantworten. Es gibt auch einige, die äh denke ich neu sind. Ähm ich würde nochmal, wie gesagt, Eingangs sagen, mir ist wichtig, dass Leute verstehen, was das Ding macht und verstehen, was es nicht macht. Und das,
die Entscheidung, das kannst du jetzt nutzen oder nicht, die soll wirklich jede Person selber treffen, vor ihrem individuellen äh Schutzbedarf
und äh ihrer Potenzial ihrer eigenen Risikoeinschätzung. Ich habe das in diesen Presse äh Interviews in den letzten Tagen gerne mal so verglichen. Ne, wenn du jetzt
eine Teenagerin Hass, die mehrere Stunden am Tag auf ähm,
Instagram, Facebook, Twitter, WhatsApp und YouTube verbringt.
Dann wäre ich jetzt vorsichtig der Annahme, dass jetzt für ihre Privatsphäre, die Nutzung dieser App im Zweifelsfall eine sekundäre Sorge wäre
ja, um das mal diplomatisch auszudrücken. Wenn ich mir aber jetzt eine investigative Journalistin vorstelle, ne, die vielleicht irgendwie mit.
Höchst ähm brisanten Quellen sich trifft oder sowas, ja, da die kann vielleicht auch die Entscheidung haben, zu sagen, auch in einer dezentralen Datenspeicherung ähm,
mit irgendwie Verschlüsselung und einem kann ich von Berufsgründen jegliches Risiko, dass sie irgendeine Aufzeichnung von irgendetwas stattfindet.
Überhaupt nicht,
tolerieren und in in Erwägung ziehen, und die könnte dann jetzt zum Beispiel die Entscheidung treffen, zu sagen, ich werde diese App nicht benutzen, ich werde diese App nicht installieren oder ich lasse mein Handy zu Hause oder ich mache von der Funktion äh gebraucht diese App,
auszuschalten. Diese Funktion bringt die App ja auch mit, ja? Und dass solche Entscheidungen und Erwägungen informiert, getroffen werden, ist unser Ziel,
das wird bei dieser Sendung von Tim sehr gut äh im Detail nochmal beschrieben und das äh denke ich.
Würden wir hier uns auch nochmal als Ziel setzen und vor diesem Hintergrund sollen Menschen dann eine Entscheidung treffen. Vor.
Von Seiten des CCC, für den ich ja auch sehr ausführlich mich in diese Debatte eingebracht habe, haben wir mit der Veröffentlichung der zehn Prüfsteine gesagt, wenn wir,
Große Bauschmerzen mit einer App haben, dann werden wir vor der Verwendung warnen. Und das wäre dann eben dann, so die,
Vollaussage für alle Menschen gewesen, so, nein, das unter kein kommt unter keinen Umständen, für irgendwem in Frage und ähm wir haben aber auch gesagt, wir werden niemals irgendetwas konkret empfehlen,
und äh genau das tun wir jetzt nämlich auch. Nichts empfehlen und nicht davon abraten. Das ist das, was der CC jetzt an dieser Stelle macht.
Auch wenn's ein bisschen schwierig ist für dich.
Du sprichst auf diesen äh Tweet von von Bericht aus äh von Bericht aus Berlin an, ne.
Ja.
Kann man den Katze den einspielen? Das Audio.
Äh den kann ich äh auch mal einspielen.
Es ist für uns auch nicht eine alltägliche Erfahrung, dass wir vor Risiken warnen und auch von Seiten der Bundesregierung auf uns gehört wird. Ich bin jetzt hier in der Situation.
Bei einer Veröffentlichung von SAP deutscher Telekom und Bundesregierung keine nennenswerten Mängel beklagen zu können. Das ist auch für mich jetzt schwierig.
Ja. Solche Tage gibt's.
Solche Tage geht's ja.
Komm da muss man mal aus seinen äh Gewohnheiten ausbrechen. Ist ja auch nicht allen gelungen. Ähm kommen wir zum,
zu der, ich glaube, der die erste und wahrscheinlich auf wichtigste Frage, die so gestern,
aufkam, als die Leute anfing, diese Äpfel installieren, da meldeten sich dann einige Android-Nutzerinnen und sagten äh diese App.
Verlangt, die Aktivierung der Locationdienste. Fuck, ich habe gedacht, dass sie genau das nicht.
Tut
auf meine Location zugreifen. Und interessanterweise, also ich hatte dann ähm, ich hatte auch gerade so ein Android, mein Android-Testgerät hier in der Hand und hatte da immer die Institut, diese Warnung auch bekommen, habt ihr dann gelesen, sie ist,
das muss ich auch zugeben. Also.
Sie ist natürlich total missverständlich und hinderlich, wenn man sie genau liest, ist sie aber koinhaltlich korrekt, aber natürlich ist sie für die, für die Experience der Nutzerin ein Problem. Jetzt muss man erklären, wie kommt es zu dieser.
Zu dieser Meldung.
Erstmal sagen, was diese Meldung sagt, also man startet halt diese äh App und dann möchte sie gerne ein Feature.
Freigeschaltet bekommen vom Betriebssystem, man kennt ja diese
Meldungen, die dann hochgebracht werden und ich äh besitze das jetzt hier mal frei, also ist ja hier auf Englisch, also äh möchte gerne halt die weißlocation haben, als als Feature
und äh das sei halt jetzt äh erforderlich, um Bluetooth Geräte in der Nähe zu erkennen,
und äh die Kuh wird neunzehn Benachrichtigungen äh benutzt es aber nicht.
Ja, so andere Apps mit diesem Zugriff äh werden dann zu meiner, zu meinem, zu meiner Device-Location Zugriff haben. Also, man hätte es wirklich nicht bekloppt, da formulieren können.
Genau, also der ist ganz fürchterlich formuliert, aber es ist korrekt, ja? Und wenn man versteht, was sich dahinter verbirgt, dann ist auch klar, warum das da genauso steht. Also ähm.
Dass das Betriebssystem selber hat einen Service,
und dieser Service, den sie den es Apps bereitstellen kann, heißt.
Lokationsdienste. Und über diese Lokationsdienste gibt es mehrere Quellen über die sich das.
Telefon bedienen und lokalisieren kann. Drei Beispielhafte sind AGPS B, WLAN äh Signale, also es gibt quasi Android pflegt eine
äh oder Google pflegt eine Karte der WLAN-Empfangsstärken an verschiedenen Orten und Mapp darauf auf eine Lokation. Und ähm der Dritte ist eben die Bluetooth
Beatens, die ja hier auch bei der Kurve äh neunzehn Corana Corona Warn-App.
Anwendung finden, deren ursprüngliche Anwendungszweck ja, die Indoor-Navigation ist in der Navigation deshalb, weil wenn du jetzt in
hatte ja immer das Beispiel eines Museums genannt, in diesem Museum, das hatten vielleicht ein großes Dach oben drüber, deswegen hast da kein GPS und wenn man jetzt ähm.
Eine App eine Begleitapp für das Museum haben möchte, machen wir einfach an jedes Exponat zum Bluetooth bieten und die,
Museumsapp zeigt ihr einfach immer die Information zu dem Exponat an, dessen biegen sie am stärksten empfängt, ne? Das ist also diese Bluetooth-Bieten, die da verwendet werden, sind eigentlich für Indoor Navigation gedacht gewesen,
Nun ist es also so, dass,
diese App ja auf diese Bluetooth bietens zugreifen muss. Da sind wir jetzt aber auf der Appebene,
Der Schalter lokationsdienste ist auf der ähm,
auf der Betriebssystemebene. Also ihr könnt quasi in Android für das gesamte Telefon.
An und alle nachgeordneten Apps und alles, was das Telefon tut, die Möglichkeit des Zugriffs auf Lokationsdienste ausschalten. Die Folge ist dann, dass dieses Gerät diese Dienste überhaupt nicht verwendet, die sind aus,
So, demnach gelagert gibt es die zweite Ebene ähm.
Welcher App erlaube ich denn den Zugriff? Also, du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, ich mache Lokations, mein Telefon soll grundsätzlich Lokationsdienste nutzen.
Aber WhatsApp darf nicht darauf zugreifen, Instagram darf nicht darauf zugreiben, aber was weiß ich, Telegramm darf darauf zugreifen.
Ja, das ist die zweite Ebene, wo also bei einer App gesagt wird, du darfst, du darfst nicht, du darfst du das nicht.
Was ich so nochmal so eine feiere, also eine positive Negativliste.
Genau, da wird also gerade App Application, ne, diese App darf auf diese zugreifen, diese nicht. Und
bei denjenigen, die das auf dem ganzen Telefon ausgeschaltet haben, dieses also zum Beispiel auch die können dann nicht, wenn sie Google Maps aufmachen, sehen sie auch nicht, wo sie sind. Ne? Das Telefon kann das einfach überhaupt nicht
Und wenn man das, wenn man diesen Schalter hatte, dann sagt diese App, du musst das jetzt machen, damit.
Überhaupt dein Gerät diese Bluetooth-Biekens nutzen kann. So und dann sagt es konsequent, wir werden aber nicht auf GPS oder irgendwelche Lokationen zugreifen.
Können und dürfen sie auch nicht, haben Apple und Google schon im ich glaube im Mai oder April im Mai glaube ich bekannt gegeben.
Ja, also die, das ginge nicht, wenn diese App auf die Location zugreifen würde, dann würde würde Apple und Google sie jeweils nicht freischalten, die Cam nicht auf euer Handy. Und jetzt kommt hier diese letzte, letzte Hinweis, andere Apps,
mit der Erlaubnis auf die Location zuzugreifen,
werden dann auch den Zugriff haben. Wenn du nun diese Locationdienste einschaltest. Wenn du diesen anderen Apps das aber auch nicht gegeben hast, dann hast du halt auch überhaupt gar kein Problem. Jetzt kommt die Konsequenz.
Und das ist das, was äh richtig geraten wurde, von vielen auf Twitter. Na ja, dann macht doch die Location-Dienste an und schalte aber wie der GPS aus. Das geht nämlich. Denn Locationdienste selber ist wieder eine Abstraktion für diese unterschiedlichen Dienste.
Erstaunliche, also ich meine, ich hoffe, ich hab's jetzt gut erklärt und ich habe auch etwas länger gebraucht oder wir. Und er ist, es ist.
Erstaunlich, dass auch in seriösen Medien
dieser Zusammenhang falsch und oder sage ich mal, sehr stark missverständlich dargestellt wurde, ist aber auch bei dieser Art Fehlermeldung und dieser Eile, mit der sich die Journalisten und Journalistinnen damit auseinandersetzen mussten, vielleicht auch kein Wunder.
Also, ganz ehrlich, ich habe mir das dreimal durchgelesen und ich habe immer noch nicht geschnallt, was die, was sie mir sagen wollen.
Aber jetzt hast du es geschnallt.
Das ihr jetzt habe ich's, glaube ich, ansatzweise begriffen, aber so ein Hinweis wie, ja.
Bitte erlaube mir Zugriff auf die auf diese Lokationsdienste, aber deine App braucht die gar nicht.
Aber die anderen Apps, die haben sie dann alle.
Aber nur wenn du die ihn gegeben hast.
Das ist.
Ist korrekt.
Nein, nein,
nee, sorry, da gibt's überhaupt gar keine Entschuldigung für. Das ist einfach die Definition von schlechten User-Interface-Design. Also das, das ist einfach, da muss man das, das ist das, was ich auch an Android so
Hasse. So. Ja, ich meine auf Eiweiß, da kommt die App hoch und sagt, ja, hier möchtest du Kontaktprotokoll für Kurve haben? Ja.
Anschalten, willst du Nachrichten kriegen? Ja, anschalten, fertig.
Und so einfach jetzt sein können und verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, warum sie da nicht einfach nochmal einen zweiten Kanal daneben gemacht haben, der mit diesen ganzen anderen Quatschen nichts zu tun hat. Na, egal. Äh Google, was weiß ich.
Also kurz gesagt, äh umso mal ganz einfach zu sagen, wenn ihr Lokationsdienste ausgeschaltet habt
dann kann das Gerät nicht auf diese Bluetooth Schnittstelle zugreifen und deswegen muss das aktiviert werden, sonst funktioniert die App nicht. Sie greift aber nicht auf eure Lokation zu. Das ist, glaube ich, der Teil, den man sich merken muss und diese Warnung bekommen auch nur die Menschen, die Lokationsdienste vollständig deaktiviert hatten, was jetzt wieder darum führt.
Dazu führte, dass andere, die das die Locationdize nicht aktiviert hatten, Angst hatten, weil sie diese Warnung nicht bekommen haben, also es ist äh, es ist unterhaltsam.
Dann ähm eine Sorge, die das auch sehr geil ist, äh genau gehen wir mal wirklich die Sorgen durch die die zweitgrößte Sorge, die Menschen eigentlich hatten, war.
Dass ihr Akku schneller leer geht,
Das war wirklich, das war in allen irgendwie Social Dingern fragen so. Ja, aber mein Akku so. Ähm ja, das Ding hat, ich meine, alles, was euer Handy macht, hat Einfluss auf die Akku-Laufzeit, ähm, den tatsächlichen Effekt werden wir sehen,
ich weiß, dass in den EP, also in den Diskussionen, mit Apple und Google, sich durchaus darüber Gedanken gemacht wurde.
Und das ist auch einer der Punkte, warum diese App relativ, also eigentlich die ganze Zeit bietend sendet, aber nur alle fünf Minuten empfängt, weil äh interessanterweise also vielleicht für,
für Menschen, die sich nicht so sehr mit Radiotechnik auseinandersetzen, äh überraschend ist es so, dass empfangen zumindest im digitalen Bereich mehr Energie braucht als Senden,
den Sendenteil kann man einfach in Hardware,
schmal vor sich hinsenden lassen, aber das Empfang erfordert ja immer auch eine Verarbeitung des Signales, potenziell das Schreiben in die ähm in die Datenbank, sodass hier ähm eben die Haup.
CPU des Gerätes tatsächlich tätig sein muss, während man dieses Aussenden von Bietens eben in in Hardware mit wenig Energie einfach so vor sich hinlaufen lassen kann.
Also, ja, alles, was euer Handy macht hatten, Einfluss auf den Energieverbrauch, aber ich halte es für relativ unwahrscheinlich, dass jetzt ähm.
Lass jetzt auf einmal euer Akku nur noch einen halben Tag dauernd oder so, ne? Und jede Sekunde
jede Sekunde Display anzuhaben an dem Telefon und irgendwie mal eben Twitter zu checken, hat im Zweifelsfall einen stärkeren Effekt auf den Akku, als jetzt irgendwie eine Stunde oder zwei von dieser Bluetooth-Bietenverarbeitung.
Vorsichtige schätzen.
Ja, weil das jetzt auch gerade auf Twitter äh so rumgeht und ich bin auch durch einen etwas äh schlecht formulierten Twitter, habe ich ein bisschen mitschuldig gewesen. Ähm man kann,
bei den iPhones äh in den Settings, der Batterie kann man sich so anzeigen lassen, welche Apps denn jetzt hier eigentlich am meisten Strom verbraucht haben.
Aha, stimmt.
Und da gibt es dann, da gibt es dann tatsächlich für dieses Kontaktprotokoll einen eigenen Eintrag.
Und wenn man das dann halt hoch aufruft, so, dann hat man dann sowas wie, ja, hier Kurve, Kontaktprotokoll.
Hat vier Prozent von deinem Akku weggehabst hat. So und ähm ich hatte mich da kurz,
zu einer Mc Weltredoren kurz drüber ausgetauscht und kam alle an so, ja, bei mir sind's sieben Prozent, bei mir sind's zehn Prozent und so weiter. Ähm merkte ich schon so, oh weia! Jetzt.
Ist die Wahrnehmung irgendwie, ja, dass das jetzt zehn Prozent meines Akkus weghamstert, ja.
Aber das, das Miss doch nur, wenn die App im Vordergrund ist, oder?
Ähm ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, was es mist, aber es sind Prozente. Das heißt, das bedeutet, umso weniger du dein Telefon benutzt hast,
umso höher wird dieser Prozent.
Oh ja ja.
Wenn du aber die ganze Zeit mit deinem Telefon rumduddelst, ja? Dann wird natürlich dieser Prozentanteil entsprechend sinken. Ja, da ist die ganze Zeit, was
aktiv, das verbraucht auch irgendwie Strom, weil es halt alle fünf Minuten mindestens mal ein Telefon aufweckt, aber wenn du Dinge die ganze Zeit sowieso am Feuern hast und durch dein Facebook Timeline durch äh brauchst so
Das ist das, was wirklich Strom verbraucht. So. Also diese Prozentangabe ist an der Stelle im Prinzip eine Null Ansage.
Vor allem jetzt kommt auch noch auch das wieder, ne.
In dieser Anzeige, ich habe hier mal meinen Test iPhone äh liegen. Ähm in dieser Anzeige ist ja, steht für die Chorona Warnapp null Prozent Akkuverwendung, weil die App ist ja nicht auf und für
vier Prozent, ja. Das ist äh äh zum Vergleich,
Ähm ich das ist natürlich jetzt auch sehr außergekräftig, sagen wir mal so die die Anwendungen,
für Twitter, für Webbrowsen und für Podcast hören, äh summieren sich bei mir zu sechzig Prozent Akku.
Ja. Also, meine Leute ist auch nicht kleinreden, ja, es wird Batterieverbrauch geben.
Und der wird auf älteren Geräten unter Umständen auch noch etwas mehr durchschlagen, als bei neueren Geräten? Weil die einfach.
Besser optimiert sind und mehr Akku sowieso haben. Das äh gibt es einfach so mit sich. Und äh es gibt ja auch ein klare Lied äh von Leuten mit ganz alten Telefonen, dass das die jetzt nicht mehr unterstützt werden.
Wobei man äh da sagen, also es gibt offensichtlich dann doch noch eine ganze Menge Leute, die mit so iPhone, sechs und iPhone fünf S äh rumlaufen.
Das würde dir nicht passieren.
Na ja, ich hatte sowas bis vor kurzem hier auch noch rumliegen, aber ich äh werde mich da jetzt wenig drüber beklagen, dass äh dass die nicht unterstützt werden, weil da gibt's
mehrere gute Gründe äh dafür, der der Hauptgrund ist natürlich, dass die ganz alten iPhones halt einfach über diese Bluetooth Energy Technologie nicht verfügen,
so und ähm besondere Verwirrung gab's halt bei iPhone.
Sechs, was sozusagen der Sex S ist unterstützt. Es ist konkret diese Sechserserie,
die halt äh rausgefallen ist, die ja auch nicht das neueste Betriebssystem Update mehr bekommt, ne und.
Da wird dann angemerkt, na ja, aber da ist ja Bluetoothlow Energy nachgerüstet worden. Das stimmt auch, aber das bezieht sich nur auf einen Teil dieser Technologie und diese Highspeed-Variante davon, die ist dann nicht drin. Also, da ist da fehlt auch diese Hardwareunterstützung,
ja klar, also wer jetzt so ein Telefon noch benutzt und kein Geld und keine Lust hat, sich ein neues zu kaufen.
Sorry ja, da ist dann einfach die Technologie, für die man sich jetzt entschieden hat, so noch nicht da und deswegen wird sie da auch nicht unterstützt werden. Und so ist es halt leider.
Das ist jetzt bei, das ist bei Apple noch ein ähm einfach zu kennzeichnendes Problem, ja, zu sagen, okay, die Linie verläuft zwischen Modellgeneration sechs und sechs S. Ähm.
Viel Spaß in in der Android-Feld. Ja, äh wo du ja jetzt dann ähm ganz, ganze Reihe unterschiedlicher Hersteller hast, die unterschiedliche Betriebssystem
ähm Versionen unterstützen, unterschiedliche Hardware drin haben und dann noch,
potentiell, ne, die Play-Services haben oder nicht, je nachdem, was für ein Android oder hast. Da kommen wir gleich in einer anderen Frage auch nochmal drauf zurück.
Ich würde jetzt nochmal ganz kurz bei den Nutzerinnen sorgen sein, dass andere Dinge nach dem Akku, was ist das nächste, worüber die Leute sich Sorgen machen? Daten.
Was mit meinen Daten. Also, Datenverbrauch. Und ähm also Datenspeicher, ne, die teure SD-Karte, die wir ins Android gesteckt haben und äh wenn das da jetzt regelmäßig Daten runterlädt, wie viele sind das denn.
Und da kam eine Ankündigung, da muss ich sagen, die hatten mich überrascht, das da habe ich nicht mit gerechnet oder das wusste ich einfach nicht, dass das so sein würde, dass nämlich Tim Hötkes äh Vorstandsvorsitzender Deutsche Telekom sagt
der Traffic zu diesen Servern wird bei allen deutschen Mobilfunkanbietern. Wusstest du das.
Äh ich wusste, dass es Gespräche gab.
Aber ich wusste nicht, dass es schon äh zu dieser Entscheidung gekommen ist. Und insofern war ich auch etwas äh überrascht. In gewisser Hinsicht angenehm überrascht, weil an der Stelle macht mal Seroritin mal,
mal Sinn, weil ja hier kein äh einzelner Anbieter bevorteilt wird, sondern die Gesellschaft hier ihren Schärkrecht.
Ja ähm wir haben
über dieses ganze Zero Rating hier so oft und so viel gesprochen. Es ist eine Verletzung der Netzneutralität. Das ist ein komplettes riesiges Fass. Wir beide würden uns lieber wünschen, dass es einfach viel mehr
beziehungsweise viel mehr Datenvolumen beziehungsweise keine Grenzen mehr dafür gibt, dass sich solche Fragen nicht stellen. Es ist natürlich auch in der heutigen Zeit eben dann doch auch ein ein Zeichen für, für die, für den,
Entwicklungsstand dieses Landes, dass wir uns bei sowas immer noch Sorgen machen müssen, ob wir unser Datenvolumen reicht, aber das ist, denke ich mal, hier die kurze und wichtige Antwort, es gibt dieses Zero Rating.
Und das ist auch total sinnvoll, weil es halt einfach, wenn man mal die Zahlen hochrechnet, da kann schon einiges zusammenkommen,
insbesondere wenn der nächste Schritt gemacht wird in der Entwicklung, der ja derzeit noch nicht genommen wurde, dass einfach die europäischen Länder zusammengelegt werden und äh.
EU
im ersten Schritt wahrscheinlich, vielleicht ja auch noch darüber hinaus. Also, dass diese Gatevase in andere Länder, die dieselbe äh Abtechnologie verwenden, dass die geöffnet werden und
dann kann's halt schnell mal viel werden. So und dann.
Kann's sein, dass man dann allein nur im Download bedarf, hm so im Jahr äh Entschuldigung, im Monat äh so eine anderthalb Gigabyte zusammenkommt.
Und es gibt halt so all die Verträge und so weiter, die haben halt auch dann nicht mehr im Monat. Klar, wenn das über das WLAN geht, alles kein Problem und das wird vielleicht auch oft so sein, aber.
Soll ja sofort funktionieren, wenn Informationen da sind, will man nicht erst auf WLAN warten. Insofern guter Move.
Äh das war auch eine der häufigen Fragen, die gestellt wurden. Ja, was ist denn mit der internationalen Nutzung,
Ähm dazu.
Ist die die Antwort, das ist zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt noch nicht möglich. Es liegt aber in meinen Augen,
weniger an den technischen Gegebenheiten, als am Meldewesen. Meldewesen damit meine ich
Es muss ja immer sichergestellt werden, dass eine Person, die sich dort als äh infiziert meldet und damit eine Warnung rausgeben möchte, dadurch, dass sie ihre Codes hochlädt, auch wirklich infiziert ist,
Dieser Verifikationsprozess ähm ist das, worin sich die Länder ja potentiell unterscheiden. Und ich hatte.
Ähm ja hier auch schon ähm vorher mal.
Dieses, dieses, also, wir hatten hier angesprochen, dass Google und Apple der Spraywork gebaut haben, dass es überall gleich, also,
die Apps, die darauf jetzt setzen, was nach meiner Kenntnis, die Schweiz, Lettland, ähm Österreich, Italien.
Auf jeden Fall bis Ende dieses Monats sein werden. Bei anderen Ländern bin ich gerade nicht so im Bilde. Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass das jetzt sich sehr stark verbreiten wird. Aber ich hatte ja gesagt
Apple und Googles schaffen hier diese technischen, diesen technischen Standard, überlassen aber das Heavy Lifting,
nämlich diesen ganzen Mist zu verwalten und zu kontrollieren, den Ländern oder den dortigen App-Herstellern. Und da wird sich jetzt zeigen.
A, wie löst man technisch, dass ein Deutscher sagt, ich möchte auch in Italien und zweitens, wie sorgt man dafür, dass sie italienischen Behörden,
diese Meldung des deutschen akzeptieren, das ist einfach bis jetzt noch nicht geregelt, gibt's verschiedene Ansätze, für werden auch in dem UKW,
von Tim mit den Entwicklern genau im Detail mit Nachteil besprochen. Ich denke merken, muss man sich ähm im Moment gibt es diese, dieses internationale Meldewesen nicht, daran wird jetzt gearbeitet und das wird sicherlich nachgereicht und
technische Grundlage in diesem Exporcher Notification Framework ist auf jeden Fall da.
Genau, also was auf jeden Fall da ist, ist die Kompatibilität
also die Art und Weise wie halt die ähm diese Funkfeuer äh gestaltet sind, die ausgestrahlt werden von den Telefon. Die sind halt in
allen Teilnehmern des dezentralen Modells, sage ich mal, kompatibel. Das heißt, im Prinzip kann man die alle mischen und austauschen. Was noch fehlt und da erwarte ich
demnächst ein Up,
dieser dieses Fremdworks und dieser ganzen AP, von Google und Apple, da wird sicherlich nochmal eine neue Version ausgerollt werden, wo dann eben die Telefone zumindest, also die Apps, dann diese Informationen bekommen,
wenn ich jetzt so Kies hochlade, an welchem Tag war ich wo? Also, nicht
wo war ich genau im Sinne von GPS und Standort, sondern in welchem Land.
Genau. Ja Tim, aber das ist jetzt auch nur ein Vorschlag von mehreren. Deswegen habe ich ja gerade auf deine Sendung verwiesen,
ich würde das an dieser Stelle kurz halten, weil
die das ist eine, das ist noch nicht technisch implementiert, die Abwägung habt ihr in eurem Podcast besprochen, ich würde an dieser Stelle aber noch eine Sache gerne korrigieren, weil nämlich die Leute davon ausgehen
äh wenn ich jetzt aber irgendwie nach Italien fahre, muss ich dann die italienische installieren, die kriege ich ja gar nicht da drauf. Ich denke, das,
sollte und dürfte eigentlich nicht der Fall sein, ja? Weil ähm
dein Handy wird nichts anders machen, wenn du jetzt die italienische App drauf hast und wenn überhaupt müsstest du die italienische Potenziell nur zu melden dann noch installieren und eigentlich sollte der,
die Lösung, dieses Problem ist, ähm, beinhalten, dass du immer nur eine App raus und in der Lage bist, in anderen äh Ländern zu einer, zu einer Auslösung zu führen. Es gibt ja noch das.
Andere Problem, was ja auch noch gelöst werden muss, trifft eine deutsche in der Schweiz.
Wen muss sie jetzt Neuti fallen? Ja, also wie gesagt, das wird noch spezifiziert werden, Details dazu gibt's bei KW. Sollen wir, sollen wir es dabei belassen.
Ja, vielleicht noch eine Anmerkung. Also, gibt da zwei Ebenen, ne? Das eine ist so, welche App benutze ich unnotifiziert zu werden? Da kann man halt im Ausland auch die eigene Benutzen, dass es Sinn der Sache, dass man dabei bleibt. Was aber wirklich noch ein ungelöstes Problem ist, ist was ist, wenn ich jetzt,
zwei Wochen in Italien bin und ich kriege dort.
Die Mitteilung hier, mach mal Quarantäne, mach mal Test, da fahre ich ja dann nicht nach Deutschland zurück, um den Test zu machen, weil.
Das heißt, dann muss man wirklich vor Ort den Test machen und dann ist das so mit dieser Kompaktibilität so eine Sache. Es ist aber so, dass man sehr wohl umschalten kann. Also man könnte tatsächlich sagen, oh jetzt lade ich mir mal hier Immuni, die italienische App runter,
aktiviere die? Da gehen die Daten nicht verloren und dann kann ich halt auch einen in Italien gemachten Test,
in mit dem weiß nicht ganz genau wie das da abläuft. Also mit deren Prozess äh dann auch äh melden. Das wäre möglich. Ist alles nicht so schön.
Würde sich also Lohn, aber das müsstest du erst machen, bei melden, weil dein Handy würde ja trotzdem.
Genau, also benachrichtigt benachrichtigt wird man äh auch im Ausland, wenn diese ganze internationale Vernetzung dann,
hergestellt ist, damit rechne ich so in den nächsten vier bis sechs Wochen vielleicht und äh diese Meldegeschichte ist dann der nächste Schritt, den man äh noch lösen muss. Viele Leute haben auch Probleme, die App
runterzuladen, die nicht im deutschen App Store sind, zum Beispiel, das ist auch noch so ein Problem, was aufgekommen ist
äh meiner Erkenntnis nach soll sich das noch ändern, dass sie dann doch ein bisschen freier verfügbar ist, weil wir haben halt das weiß ich auch so türkische Mitbürger, die dann eben.
Türkische App Store benutzen, also so quasi für das Telefon irgendwie mehr oder weniger in der Türkei leben, obwohl sie hier sind.
Ähnliche äh Geschichten, mit Leuten, die auch hier für ein paar Monate äh wegen Fernstudium oder so weiter äh sind, aber nicht so ohne Weiteres dann mal so ein so ein Wechsel vornehmen können
die derzeit an dieser App schlicht nicht rankommen, was natürlich Quatsch ist, deswegen liegt davon aus, dass diese Beschränkung aufgehoben werden wird.
Genau. Also, eine Reihe an Problemen, die an deren Lösung gerade gearbeitet wird.
Was nicht um den Problem sind, an deren Lösung gerade gearbeitet wird, äh sind die dann doch medial an einigen ähm in einigen Medien.
Aufgegriffenen Angriffe, die es auf dieses Protokoll.
Gäbe und ich würde vorsichtig beurteilen, was da stattgefunden hat, ist etwas vergleichbar.
Mit dem, was in der Diskussion,
des Wissenschaftswissenschaftlichen Forschungspapers des Teams um Christian Drosten passiert ist,
dass hier eine Akademische Auseinandersetzung geführt wird und eine akademische Forschung betrieben wird und.
Äh mediale, die mediale Aufbereitung dieser.
Auseinandersetzung nicht ganz so informiert erfolgt, wie die akademische Auseinandersetzung, um das mal vorsichtig und diplomatisch zu sagen.
Es war eine Forschergruppe der Uni Darmstadt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Die verschiedene Angriffsszenarien, die wir schon im März diskutiert hatten.
Die quasi bekannt waren unter Realweltbedingungen.
Nachgestellt, hat und damit quasi belegt hat, ja, diese Angriffsszenarien bestehen.
Und das betrifft spezifisch das sogenannte.
Äh Warmholing, also Wurmlochen, ja und das die Idee wäre hier.
Tim und ich das heißt für diese Zeit, die wir jetzt nicht miteinander verbringen,
erhalten wir auch keine Notifications. Wenn es nun ein Gerät gäbe, was bei Tim ist und seine Bietensempfängt, dann.
Im Zweifelsfall über das Internet an ein zweites Gerät sendet, was diese bietens dann auch wieder aussendet.
Dann würde mein Testgerät mein Android-Testgerät, was hier liegt, ähm.
Diese Bietensempfang und sammeln. Und dann würde sich vielleicht Potenziell der Tim irgendwann als Infektionsmelden oder als infiziert melden und mein Gerät hier würde ein ausgeben. Und jetzt,
ist natürlich anzumerken. Ich bin dem Tim nicht begegnet, dieser wäre also zu einhundert Prozent falsch.
Ja
das ist eine vollkommen bekannte Schwäche des Systemes, die hier demonstriert wird mit eigens hergestellter Hardware, einem eigens gebauten System für diese Art Störung, ja? Jetzt.
Ist aber euch sicherlich aufgefallen, damit ich da überhaupt irgendetwas von Merkel und irgendein Problem habe.
Muss der Tim sich immer noch krank melden, ich merke also überhaupt nichts von diesem Angriff oder von diesem Problem, solange sich nicht diese Person, deren Bietens mir da gesendet werden
auch noch krank meldet. Ähm jetzt könnte man also sagen, okay, wir bauen so ein Gerät, wir nehmen ein Handy, ja? Und dann und dann senden wir diese Codes ganz viel.
Überall hin geben ganz viel Geld aus, damit wir ein ein vielen Orten dieser Erde, diese Biegen senden können und dann melden wir uns krank und dann kriegen die Leute alle einen Alarm.
Das äh ist möglich. Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage wie stehen hier.
Der von den Angreifern zu betreiben, der Aufwand im Verhältnis zu ihrem Ertrag. Das wäre.
Jetzt relativ schwach, ja? Was ich mir eher vorstellen könnte, wäre, ich will jetzt hier niemand auf falsche Ideen bringen, aber zum Beispiel eine Schulklasse.
Die in der Pause einfach mal ein Handy in die Mitte legt, die anderen im Kreis drum herum, das Ganze mal äh für die große Pause, eine halbe Stunde so liegen lässt und dann das Handy in der Mitte,
gezielt krank meldet, damit alle anderen ein paar Tage frei bekommen, ja? Das wären eher so Szenarien, die ich erwarten würde. Das,
Zweite, was die ähm beschrieben haben.
Ist äh DANO Nimisierung ähm und Tracking,
Und da bin ich ja schon, also da bin ich ja dann hellhörig geworden, ja? Und habe sie, wir können Bewegungsprofile anlegen. Aha, wie macht ihr das denn, ne? Tja, ganz einfach,
sie schaffen sich,
ein Sensornetzwerk aus Bluetoothempfängern, verteilen das an ganz vielen Orten und kombinieren dieses Sensornetzwerk mit einer anderen Identitätsfeststellenden Technologie, beispielsweise Gesichtserkennung,
oder ähm.
Äh oder was weiß ich, Kreditkartenzeit oder so. Irgendetwas, wo du eine eindeutige Identifizierung einer Person hast und dann gleichzeitig guckst, was sie, was sie zu dem Zeitpunkt von Bieten gesendet hat, ja?
Und dann läuft die Person jetzt, also quasi durch dein Sensornetzwerk und alle äh alle regelmäßigen identifire Wechsel verlierst du eigentlich auch wieder, das Tracking
ja? Weil die Sende jetzt auf einmal neue Codes aus. Wenn sie sich aber nun,
dann eine von den wenigen Personen ist die sich nachher als infiziert melden, dann hast du, dann hat sich der ganze Aufwand gelohnt, weil jetzt hast du
kannst du sehen, wie diese Person, weil sie ihren Kieferöffentlich hat, wie sie sich durch deinen Weltumspannen des Bluetoothsensorennetzwerk bewegt hat, wer sie ist und.
Ähm,
äh was ihr äh Status ist, nämlich der, dass sie äh sich Infektions gemeldet hat. Also für, sage ich mal, ein Mittelstelligen, Milliardenbetrag äh könntest du also mit einem
deutschlandweiten Gesichtserkennungssystem und einer entsprechenden Anzahl von äh Bluetooth Sensoren hier eine vollständige Anonymisierung
der äh Kurve erkrankten vornehmen und ich denke, dieser Business Case, der wird ja nicht lange auf sich warten lassen.
Und das Ganze noch mit bis zu vierzehn Tagen Verzögerung. Also.
Ja und also ich denke, man muss dazu sagen, ja, dass ähm muss da jetzt wirklich sehr vorsichtig zu sagen. Also, wenn ich.
Derartige Erfassungsmöglichkeiten hätte, ja? Mit 'nem mit 'nem Gesichtserkennungssystem und riesigen Bluetooth Sensoren, Netzwerk, dann.
Dann würde ich damit vielleicht was anderes machen, ne? Also da hätte ich, hätte ich jetzt wildere Fantasien, was ich damit anrichten kann, als ähm als das, was hier beschrieben ist.
Ja, da wäre dann auch diese diese Warnapp auch nicht unbedingt das erste Ziel. Also da da könnte man auf ganz andere äh äh Dinge äh gehen und das.
Das ist halt das Absurde an dieser ganzen Debatte, aber dann wie du ja schon ein ganz richtig gesagt hast, ne? Man muss einfach unterscheiden zwischen so einem Security Paper, was einfach mal sagt, okay, wir haben das jetzt auch mal ganz praktisch mal gemacht und wir zeigen auch
welchen Aufwand das braucht, ja und dann geht das
Und dann ist das eine interessante äh wissenschaftliche äh logische Feststellung so, ja, so haben wir es gemacht und das sind die Ergebnisse und hier steht es jetzt alles in diesem Payper. So, aber daraus resultiert halt nicht automatisch
eine Bedrohung mit konkrete in einem real Weltszenario, sondern das ist natürlich etwas, was man da auch noch herauslesen muss. Und das ist jetzt in dieser Berichterstattung teilweise und in Kommentaren, zu dem, zu der Veröffentlichung der App einfach,
teilweise überhaupt nicht gemacht wurden, da wurden dann einfach mehrere Paper zusammengeworfen und haben gesagt, so ja hier und da und hier noch eine Behauptung und und da noch einen Behauptung und das, also, wenn da so viel zusammenkommt, dann muss das ja unsicher sein,
So und das ist dann einfach nicht seriös.
Ja, also, dass er das, ne, das das meine ich mit dem Unterschied zwischen einer Fach
gelehrten Debatte. Großes Team da in Darmstadt, ne? Und das ist auch wichtig, also das ist wichtige Forschung, aber eben für die Forschung und nicht für irgendwelche unqualifizierten Artikel in den unqualifizierten
ähm ja Veröffentlichung. Ähm trotzdem will ich da nochmal ganz kurz zu sagen, ne? Also.
Bei Schwachstellen geht es immer auch um den Aufwand und den Ertrag und da sehe ich hier jetzt noch nicht so das Verhältnis. Ähm,
und da muss man, glaube ich, auch sehr klar sagen, dank der dezentralität und der Datensparsamkeit ist eben das Risiko für die Nutzerinnen und Nutzer an dieser Stelle minimiert, selbst wenn jetzt noch Schwachstellen gefunden werden.
Und das Gleiche Problem im zentralen Ansatz ist direkt ein viel größeres.
Also es hätte direkt viel größeres Ausmaß gehabt und dafür haben wir uns jetzt CC eingesetzt, um die App nicht zu dem,
Überwachungsalbtraum werden zu lassen, der da ursprünglich mal geplant war mit irgendwelchen Überwachung, ne? Und jetzt muss man ja immer noch sagen, das ist denke ich auch mal äh zu.
In das Verhältnis zu setzen. Die negative, die negativste Konsequenz, die wir im Prinzip von dieser App zu erwarten hast, ist ein falscher Alarm und der ist relativ.
Auch dann noch eine relativ geringe Beeinträchtigung, die du erfährst. Ähm trotzdem gehe ich davon aus, deswegen haben wir das ja hier jetzt auch nochmal besprochen.
Es wird jetzt also Effektheischerische TV-Beiträge werden nicht lange auf sich warten lassen. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass irgendein,
äh irgendeine jungen Hackerin oder irgendeinen jungen Hacker, auf jeden Fall,
jetzt noch irgendwie. Guck mal hier und mit nur wenigen hundert Bluetooth oder wenn ich jetzt mehr von diesen acht Bluetooth äh Sensoren hätte, da könnte ich die ganze Welt immer wachen, hui ui, ich habe sofort ein Video auf Instagram gepostet. Ähm
da da das wird sicherlich noch kommen. Und da wird, da wird sich schon jemand finden, dem dem solche Ängste zu schüren, nicht
zu niedrig ist und da wird die wird diese Person wird auch ein Journalist oder eine Journalistin
finden, ähm die dann nicht in der Lage ist, dass ähm korrekt einzuordnen. Insofern würde ich schon erwarten, dass dass es da irgendwo noch was geben wird.
Ja
Kann aber ganz gut sein, dass dann Riso wieder ein Video aufnehmen muss. Lass den Jungen doch mal in Ruhe. Der hat auch noch was anderes zu tun.
Die falsche Meldung ist ähm ja, da muss man, glaube ich, auch, da muss man ganz klar sagen, hier.
Ist die Technik besser als die deutsche Realität. Im Moment gibt's zur Meldung primär diese Hotline, bei der man anrufen muss.
Und das ist das große, das große Manko.
Also mit Meldungen meinst du erstmal die Information erhalten, wie der Test ausgegangen ist, um dann eine Meldung zu machen.
Die eine die eine Meldung zu machen. Gut, dass du das sagst, ne? Also ähm ich habe mein Testergebnis bekommen durch die App oder wie auch immer und gehe nun.
Komme nun in die Situation, dass ich meine Kontakte warnen möchte. Ähm und.
Um das zu tun, damit nicht andauernd irgendeinen Clown auf dem Schulhof auf den Knopf drückt, muss net, muss quasi eine Verifikation stattfinden. Und diese Ferifikation könnte.
Technisch funktionieren und diese Wege sind auch von SAP deutscher Telekom spezifiziert
ähm auf ja, gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten, das zu tun, die dort gewählte ist eine funktionierende und die hat ja zwei Schutzziele, einerseits natürlich trotzdem die Anonymität sicherzustellen und andererseits eben das Faking zu verhindern und das
ist alles ganz in Ordnung. Leider kommen wir dieses Potential nicht ausgereizt, weil man jetzt startet mit einer Telefonhotline.
Und das ist äh nicht so gut und liegt an einer mangelnden Anbindung der Labore
Ja, weil die
die elegante Lösung wäre nämlich eigentlich gewesen, wenn du im Testzentrum bist und der Q-Tip gerade aus deinem Rachen gekommen ist, gibt's eben Symproben, Begleitschein, darauf scannst du einmal einen QR-Code und dann kriegst du quasi in der App, eine anonyme Benachrichtigung über dein Ergebnis und auch die Möglichkeit dann dieses Ergebnis zu melden und
diese Kette ist zum zum Launch der App noch nicht vollständig. Das ist, denke ich sehr zu bemängeln und erhöht
auch das Risiko des äh Scherze treibens mit dieser App, was was ärgerlich ist.
Was ärgerlich ist. Ich meine, man muss sagen, jetzt ist die Infrastruktur halt hochgefahren worden, wie das mit jeder Infrastruktur ist,
Es wird jetzt erstmal eine Weile äh dauern und ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie viele Labore in Deutschland angebunden werden muss, aber es ist so eine niedrige mittelgroße, dreistellige Zahl,
und äh das bedeutet ja, dass jedes Labor muss in seiner IT,
äh eine entsprechende Erweiterung erhalten, wo dann eben dieser,
ganze Berichtsflow reingeht und dann über entsprechende Protokolle mit der Außenwelt, sprich mit dieser Corona Warn-App-Infrastruktur kommunizieren muss.
Das ist, da gibt's natürlich ganz natürlich viele Stolperfallen, ja? Weil Jesus Labor.
Die betreiben ja jetzt ihre IT nicht nach irgendeinem
Laborstandard, ja? Und das ist überall das Gleiche, sondern es ist halt mal so, mal so, mal so, da Max, ich kriege mich da nicht aus, da mag's ein paar Hersteller äh Softwarehersteller geben, die eben diesen Markt bedienen, aber sicherlich auch nicht nur einen einzigen,
und das muss halt jetzt klein klein angepasst werden und wird sicherlich seine Zeit dauern. Man ist wohl noch nicht so weit. Ähm wie lange es dauern wird.
Tja, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht, ob du da irgendwelche äh Erkenntnisse hast, aber Tatsache ist, die Hotline ist wahrscheinlich. Jetzt erstmal der,
Einzige oder zumindest der primäre Weg, der benutzt wird, äh um das äh zu machen.
Ersten Missstand, der gehört abgeschalte.
Ist auf jeden Fall ein Missstand der abgeschaltet bekommt, ne? Allerdings ist es natürlich auch so, jetzt haben wir gerade noch relativ wenige Fälle an sich und wir haben vor allem.
Zumindest über die nächsten zehn Tagen auch erstmal.
Keine Fälle, die jetzt durch die App hervorgerufen werden, weil das Ding muss sich jetzt erstmal verteilen, muss installiert werden und so weiter und dann wird, wir werden dann überhaupt erst im positiven Falle äh darüber ja äh entsprechende.
Kontakte dann auch überhaupt erst motivieren können. Von daher rollt das alles langsam los.
Insgesamt ist eine sind einfach auch hauptsächlich ein Risiko für die Akzeptanz der App ähm,
es wurde ja bei der Pressekonferenz auch gesagt, ja, dass sie ähm da der kursiert dieser Wert von zwanzig Prozent
äh Fehler, ja? Ähm deswegen müsst ihr eben auch, dass auch das übrigens eine Forderung, die wir hier sehr oft diskutiert hatten. Die negativen Effekte eines Alarms so gering wie möglich sein und die positiven so
hoch wie möglich und es ist so, dass eben diese App dann auch wie von uns empfohlen, zumindest in der jetzigen Zeit,
bei dieser geringen Anzahl Fälle. Im Prinzip das Freiticket zum Test ist. Das,
kann sich theoretisch ändern, wenn irgendwie die Laborkapazitäten in Deutschland.
Irgendwelchen traurigen Gründen wieder an ihre Grenzen kämen, ja,
dann würde da vielleicht nochmal anders agiert werden, aber im Moment, das schlimm, also das, was die App euch Schlimmes tun kann, ist.
Dass ihr euch Fall falsch alarmiert und ihr dann ein paar Tage Vorsicht walten lasst und wer würde das nicht tun.
Ja, das sieht ja äh also das ist,
ich glaube doch für eben interessiert es Menschen. Jetzt ist natürlich das Problem, wenn das jetzt jede Woche passiert, dann sagt man irgendwann auch kommen, scheiß auf die App, ne? Und wenn dann,
der richtige Alarm kommt, wo er wo erst dann wo ja wirklich infektiös seid und dann reist da irgendwie noch fünf Leute mit, weil ihr auf diesen Alarm nicht mehr gehört habt, dass es äh dann
das wäre dann scheiße, aber das ist, glaube ich, das Feintuning, was jetzt in dieser Phase auch noch passieren wird und passieren muss. Auch darüber habt ihr ja in der Sendung noch sehr ausführlich gesprochen, dass man vielleicht bei geringen Fallzahlen,
niedrigen Schwelle und somit vielleicht potenziell mehreren arbeitet und dann um dann die Daten zu sammeln, wo die richtige Entscheidungsschwelle,
sein, der die Bessere sein muss.
Um da ganz klar zu sein, was so diese Fehlalarmsachen betrifft. Also wir reden jetzt hier quasi von zwei, zweierlei Fehl,
Alarm, so der eine ist
quasi so ein Angriff mit ihm mir gelingt es in irgendeiner Form, die Hotline auszutricksen und mich ja als positiven zu verkaufen, obwohl ich das eigentlich nicht bin und mein Telefonsende dann Kies raus. Was ja dann aber auch
nur die Leute, die ich dann auch wirklich gesehen habe oder die mich gesehen haben, mit dem Telefon äh benachrichtigt. Das ist sozusagen.
Etwas, was man verhindern will, aber was jetzt auch nicht so mega,
große Auswirkungen haben wird, aber man könnte unter Umständen so eine gewisse Piergruppe damit treuen, wie du das ja vorhin schon dargelegt hast. Die andere Diskussion um Fehlalarme ist. Mir wird gesagt, ich sei jetzt in der Nähe gewesen von jemand, der
ähm positiv gemeldet ist. Der ist vielleicht auch wirklich wahr, aber ich war gar nicht in dessen Dinge
das ist dann wiederum eine Frage der richtigen Einstellung der Parameter, das kann heute noch keiner beurteilen, wie problematisch diese dieser Aspekt sein wird,
da ritzeln alle, weil das ist eine neue Technologie, die wird jetzt das erste Mal zum Einsatz gebracht, das wird ein bisschen Beobachtung und Entwicklung brauchen und dann sind wir in paar Monaten sicherlich schlauer.
Es kommt ja noch was dazu, ne? Was was auch äh glaube ich gerade nochmal zu betonen, weil du das ansprichst. In der Debatte.
Oft davon ausgegangen, dass Kontakt gleich Infektion wäre und das ist ja auch nicht der Fall, ne? Also das du bist ja auch noch bedenken.
Und äh so weiter und so fort. Gut. Ähm
eine sehr breite Debatte. Eine sehr breite Debatte, die gerade auch äh mit dem Einbringen der grünen, feinen Gesetzesentwurf äh wieder eine Rolle spielt, ist die das App Zwangs, jegliche Form von Zwang, im Bereich
dieser App. Und.
Dazu habe ich ähm im ARD extra am Montagabend mal äh da ging's dann spezifisch um Gastronomie, ja? Also es wird ja jetzt auch von einigen eben die Sorge.
Konkret verbreitet, dass ich zum Beispiel in eine, in ein Kino oder in eine Restaurant oder ähnliches nicht rein käme ohne diese App.
So, dazu ist Folgendes zu sagen. Ich bin ja, habe ich hier auch öfter angesprochen, mit einigen Gastronomen befreundet,
Die haben gerade genug Spaß damit, dass sie ja nach diesen Richtlinien die Kontaktdaten,
ihrer Besucherinnen aufzeichnen müssen. Ne, setzte dich hin an den Tisch, kriegst einen Zettel, musst deine Adresse drauf schreiben,
ja oder Kontaktmöglichkeiten. Dann gibt's Leute, die schreiben dat Unhalt, da hin, weil sie das
besser finden und verzichten halt für sich selber auf die Wirksamkeit dieser Lösung, ne, andere schreiben schon was weiß ich, vielleicht hat man irgendeine anonyme E-Mail-Adresse unter der man dann motifiziert werden möchte oder sonstiges, ja?
Diese Debatten, die die Gastronomen gerade über diesen Schnickschnack führen
ja? Da schlägt sich in größeren Restaurants tatsächlich darin nieder, dass man eine,
extra Personen nochmal anstellen muss, weil sonst, dass die sonstigen Dienstleistungen, die dort erbracht werden, ne, Getränke holen und so weiter, nicht erbracht werden können, in ausreichender Geschwindigkeit.
Weil jeder jede fünfte Besucherin diskutiert dann darüber und so weiter und so fort, ja? Ich halte das,
unter diesen Bedingungen für diesen Gastronomiebereich für äußerst unwahrscheinlich, dass jetzt eine
äh eine Betreiberin eines Restaurants. Das passt mal auf, Freunde, weil ich dat so geil finde, mit euch über diese Zettel zu diskutieren, will ich danach noch mit euch darüber diskutieren, dass ihr gezwungen werden sollt, eine App zu installieren. Im Moment sind die ja eigentlich froh über jede
äh Besucherin, die die das Restaurant beehrt. Und insofern halte ich das jetzt nicht für eine unmittelbare Gefahr, dass,
dass Gastronominnen irgendwie jetzt spezifisch so eine so etwas versuchen durchzudrücken. Ähm es wäre auch.
Unsinnig, weil sie dieser Zettelpflicht nicht entbunden würden
ja? Sie würden sich nur ein zweites Problem mit aufbürden. Das soll aber wiederum nicht heißen, dass nicht vielleicht eine gesetzliche Regelung, Vertrauensstiften wäre, denn ich habe auch schon
äh Kontakte äh hier Nachrichten bekommen. Ich habe ja ein E-Mail-Postfach. Offenbar ein relativ großes, weil da passt sehr viel rein.
Ähm wo sich jetzt Arbeitgeber bei mir melden, die sagen, ich habe mein,
angestellten Verboten diese Äpfel zu installieren. Was genauso nicht geht, ja? Und da fragst du dich dann auch. So Leute, könnt ihr einfach mal auf den Teppich bleiben und,
der demokratischen Maßgabe folgen, dass es einfach freiwillig ist, diese App zu installieren. Und das bedeutet, du kannst wieder jemanden dazu zwingen, noch jemanden.
Ähm jemanden, das verbieten.
Was man allerdings auch, ähm, was hier auch schon gehört habe, ist, dass verschiedene Unternehmen, die so ähm.
So enterpreismäßig ihre Telefone der Mitarbeiter ohnehin mit Software bespielen können, darüber nachdenken, diese App einfach zu installieren, ja? Wobei installieren ungleich im Betrieb.
Ja. Ah guter Punkt. Ja, die muss immer nochmal aktiviert werden.
Genau, die muss auf jeden Fall nochmal gestartet werden. Da finden gerade, glaube ich, ganz angeregte Debatten, mit den äh Hausdatenschützern statt habe ich jetzt nur gehört, dass die stattfinden, noch nicht wohin die tendieren,
hätte ich jetzt auch erstmal ehrlich gesagt
relativ wenig gegen Einzuwenden, ne. Äh ich bin jetzt überrascht, dass dass du das Beispiel gebracht hast mit Unternehmen äh Lehnen wollen, nicht, dass die App installiert wird.
Äh Realweltbeispiel. Ich hab's, also ich habe auch nicht gedacht, ich habe auch gedacht, wer mich jetzt irgendwie jemand.
Ja, was weiß ich, wenn du da so ein Aluhut äh als als als Chef hast.
Ich habe keine, da ist dieser Chef war, der mich da angeschrieben hat, möchte ich jetzt keine Beurteilung der Person vornehmen.
Ja, der aber ist ja durchaus vorstellbar, ne? Das weiß ja, fünf G und dann wird der Virus vielleicht noch durch die App verbreitet oder so.
So hier. Gut, aber das mag eher so ein Randproblem sein.
Ähm andererseits gibt es auch Unternehmen, die sagen, wir wollen euch jetzt alle hier wieder im Büro haben, aber wir wissen, dass Büro ein Problem ist, so bitte installiert auch alle diese App.
Also, dass das sozusagen Companypolity wird, werden wir sehen. Also, ich bin mir relativ, weil ich weiß, dass.
Dass es auch solche Überlegungen gibt bei einzelnen Unternehmen und.
Ich finde es in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar, ja, wenn man das jetzt mal aus dieser Perspektive, der ähm des des Arbeitsschutzes sieht.
Ich muss ja auch dafür sorgen, dass meine Mitarbeiter geschützt sind
Ja, die dürfen die bisschen ordentliche Stühle haben. Die müssen ihre Arbeitszeiten einhalten dürfen. Die müssen Pausen haben, et cetera. Äh es muss für Lüftung gesorgt werden, dürfen hier keine giftigen äh Materialien in der Wand verbaut werden, wo in den ganzen
umhängt und so möchte ich jetzt auch in dieser Krise, dass ihr,
zumindest gewarnt werden könnt, wenn in unserem Unternehmen irgendwo was auftritt, ne, was natürlich auch diesen Aspekt hat mit okay, wie viel Prozent meines Unternehmens muss ich jetzt runterfahren, wenn jetzt ein Mitarbeiter auf einmal positiv gemeldet ist,
in dem Moment, wo man diese App hat, kann man zumindest sagen, na ja, okay, die sind jetzt aber auch irgendwie notifiziert worden
Weil ich habe ja dafür gesorgt, dass alle das betreibt. Also habe da noch keine wirkliche Meinung dazu, wie ich damit umgehen will. Ich sage nur, solche Debatten haben wir jetzt und.
Damit müssen wir uns jetzt in irgendeiner Form auseinandersetzen. Nun um denen nochmal was obendrauf zu setzen.
Ähm was jetzt auch schon gehört habe, ist halt es gibt ja noch etwas, was derzeit noch gar nicht stattfindet. Das sind die Großveranstaltungen. Das ändert sich zwar jetzt langsam, aber ich nehme jetzt mal so das extrem Beispielfußball.
Steht ja immer auch im Mittelpunkt. Ne? Unter welchen Bedingungen kann Fußball mit Zuschauern wieder stattfinden.
Klar, wenn man so in der Neuseelandsituation ist, mit der Virus ist besiegt,
dann strömen vierzigtausend Leute und schon wieder äh sich irgendwie die an und haben Spaß miteinander. Diesen Zustand werden wir in Deutschland so nie erreichen,
Also wir werden nicht virus frei sein. Und dann ist halt die Frage, ja, ab wann können wir denn wieder alle,
in größeren Gruppen eng zusammenstehen und laut singen. Also Fußball sei ein gewisser Hitze. Abgesehen davon, dass es draußen ist,
ja? Äh bringt es alles mit, was derzeit als Bedrohung angesehen wird. Von allen Sportarten will ich da mal gar nicht reden.
Und auch da gibt's natürlich dann so Überlegungen, wie na ja, wenn ich aber jetzt als Anbieter dieser Veranstaltung, also als Veranstalter.
Also sprich der Heimverein, der das Spiel äh stattfinden lässt in seinem Stadion, sage naja wer geil, wenn ihr alle mal äh die App am Start habt.
Und das schreiben wir jetzt mal hier in unser Bundesligakonzept rein als Angebot an die Bundesregierung ähm.
Um das alles wieder zu ermöglichen. Wie geht man denn damit um.
Also ich denke, da muss man tatsächlich äh sich die Frage stellen und das da wäre ich jetzt vorsichtig, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass.
Solche super Sprayer-Events, wie so ein singender Fußballknabenchor, auf jeden Fall eines wäre. Ähm da müsste man natürlich mal prüfen, wie gut funktioniert ihr diese App da. Und ist, denn diese Mess.
Diese Messart, ne, solange beieinander und so nah in einem Fußballstadion noch das, was man eigentlich messen möchte.
Und ich halte das für,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass diese App mit ihrer Messmethode und mit ihren Entscheidungskriterien in so einem Fußballstadion unbedingt die besten Ergebnisse bringen würde. Ähnliches gilt übrigens hier für das ähm.
Berliner Berliner äh super Spradder-Event in Anfangszeichen, ne? War ja kein Supersprayer Event, aber äh hier ging es ja in einem äh Musikclub los in Berlin oder zwei Fälle gab es da, ne, irgendeinen Trompetenclub oder sowas, hieß der.
Und ähm Kater Blau in den ähm dann an, ganz zu Beginn der Zeit
als es noch gar nicht Thema war, infektiöse Personen waren. Und da wäre ich jetzt auch mal überrascht gewesen, an so einer Situation, mal so eine Chorona Warn-App zu validieren. Ich denke, die hätte da aber sehr schlechte Ergebnisse.
Warum denkst du das?
Weil in diesen.
Engkontakten und in diesen warmen Indoor-Situationen und so weiter äh die Annahmen nicht gelten, ne? Die Menschen bewegen sich vielleicht auch ganz viel in diesem
Artikel, den ich etwas unterhaltsam fand, äh der das Auseinander nahm von dieser äh Kater Holsticks Situation ähm.
Da war irgendwie die Räder davon, dass diese eine Person mit ungefähr fünfzig Menschen geknutscht und gekuschelt habe und sowas, ne? Was, wo ich jetzt auch dachte, das ist offenbar.
Sehr.
Gutes Zeug.
Sehr engagiert. Äh auf jeden Fall setzt sich sehr viel Nächstenliebe.
Ähm stattgefunden hat. So, da bin ich mal vorsichtig, weil das Kriterium äh irgendwie über eine viertel Stunde und unter einen Meter fuffzig ist in diesen Situationen nicht anwendbar, aber Tim, ich weiß, du sprichst jetzt dagegen,
lass uns mal dabei bleiben, das muss, muss man dann sehen.
Genau, das das macht man sich, aber ich sah nur diese Diskussion haben wir jetzt so, ne?
Ich würde mal so sagen, man kann ja auf jeden Fall einfach sagen, der Gästeblock muss in Karentäne.
Also, nur eine Sache noch zu deiner Einschätzung, die ich jetzt so nicht teile. Ich glaube, dass diese Messmethode gerade beim Fußball.
Sehr gut funktionieren würde, weil dieses alle fünf Minuten mal gucken und wer es in meiner Umgebung und da ist dann einer dabei gewesen, dann hast du so ein Teil eines Blogs, aber du musst nicht gleich das ganze Stadion irgendwie evakuieren,
Das ist schon mal äh schon mal ein Vorteil. Die das andere Beispiel, was du genannt hast, so größerer Club und so, da ist auch viel Bewegung mit dem Spiel. Und derzeit funktioniert die App halt so, sie schaut halt alle fünf Minuten mal nach
Ja, das heißt, da muss dann auch noch so eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung mit reinkommen, weil wenn du dich die ganze Zeit bewegst.
Also Tim, wenn du wenn du mit fünfzig Personen kuschelst und knutscht, ne? Dann musst du gucken, ob du überhaupt pro Person fünf Minuten hättest, ja? Je nachdem.
Vielleicht liegen die ja auch alle ganz passend beieinander. Man weiß es ja.
Okay, komm. Also, wir waren gerade beim App Zwang, ähm um das nochmal einzuordnen. Es gibt jetzt diese Forderungen.
Und die Positionen sind ähm.
Beide nachvollziehbar, nämlich die eine Position, die sagt, passt auf. Wenn hier, wenn ich hier keinen Zwang geben soll, dann könnt ihr auch gleichzeitig das mit einem Gesetz flankieren.
Das ist die Position
die jetzt hier von den GRÜNEN eingebracht wird von den Linken ich weiß nicht wie AfD ist glaub ich eh nur noch auf also ich meine erstens würden die nie gemeinsame Sachen machen und zweitens die AfD ja eh grade
die müssen erstmal wieder von ihrem Baum runterkommen und ähm auf denen sie da geklettert sind. Und jetzt ähm.
Gibt es eben dem Punkt dieses Argument, was ich einleuchtend finde. Und es gibt das Gegenargument, welches besagt.
Die aktuellen Datenschutzgesetze und Antidiskriminierungs und sonst was Gesetze reichen aus.
Und wenn wir jetzt überhaupt nur ein Chorona-App-Gesetz haben, dann wird das bei Atila Hildmann im Telegramm Kanal wieder rappeln, ja? Weil die dann denken, die äh die
Deutschland GmbH äh setzt jetzt den mit einem gesetzten App-Zwang durch mit der Bigates Corona Chip-App, ne? Also,
Das ist, das ist die andere Perspektive und ähm dann eben mit Blick auf die Realität quasi zu sagen, okay, gibt es hier eine, gibt es hier.
Momentan, Motivationen für Leute, eine solche Zwang durchzusetzen. Ähm,
die gibt es offensichtlich im Einzelfall, aber die sind schwer begründbar. Insofern bin ich gespannt, wie diese Debatte weitergeht.
Ähm,
eine weitere Sache, die man, glaube ich, die haben wir auch vor kurzem schon mal erklärt, aber ich will's nochmal machen, weil das auch wirklich immer das begleitet diese äh App-Diskussion wirklich irre stark in jedem Bericht eigentlich,
es hat so lange gedauert. Und die App kommt zu spät.
Wird da häufig behauptet, ne? Und da denke ich, muss ich nochmal in Erinnerung rufen, ich habe das sogar mal rausgesucht hier, ja? Ähm,
neunten oder zehnten April, also Ostern, Gründonnerstag Karfreitag, haben Apple und Google das gemeinsame Fragework angekündigt. Ab dem Moment konntest du quasi mit der,
Entwicklung beginnen,
Am fünfundzwanzigsten April hat die Bundesregierung die Entscheidung bekannt gegeben nun auch auf diesen Apple Google dezentralen Ansatz zu setzen davor haben sie auf den zentralisierten Ansatz gesetzt,
Ja, wenn ich jetzt äh sehe, dass der fünfundzwanzigste April war, der Sonntag, glaube ich, wo das bekannt gegeben wurde
die Entscheidung war aber schon eigentlich an dem Samstag oder den Freitagabend gefällt. Wenn wir da jetzt mal auf Werktage gucken, dann haben wir also zwei Wochen zehn Werktage Entwicklungszeit verloren, zehn Werktage.
Am einundzwanzigsten Mai wurde iOS dreizehn fünf released. Ich weiß nicht genau wann das Framework über die Play Services gepusht wurde bei Android.
Das war auch am selben Tag.
War das am selben Tag, ja? Ich hatte das nämlich dann auf einmal auf dem Telefon drauf und gut, das kann sein, war das derselbe Tag, um so einfacher für meine äh Zeitrechnung hier. Die ersten Apps wurden am,
neunundzwanzigsten Mai vorgestellt. Gefeiert als Erste wurde diese Schweizer App,
die aber nur in der Testphase ist. Das heißt, sie ist nicht im Produktivbetrieb, ne? Ähm, ich glaube, neunundzwanzigsten gab's dann die lettische App oder so, ne? Also, wenn man jetzt auf den Tag genau nicht rechnet, sagen wir, Ende Mai gab's die ersten Apps, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, äh falls es sich ganz genau, wenn die rausgekommen ist, aber so in etwa. Mhm.
Du, ich hatte äh.
Tim hatte Tim hat mir dabei den Zusammentrag ein bisschen geholfen. Äh deswegen frage ich, ich war nochmal sicher, aber ungefähr Ende Mai. Ich müssen jetzt auf den Tag genau nicht rechnen. Ähm und wenn wir jetzt schauen, jetzt äh releast also Deutschland am sechzehnten Juni.
Ähm also zwei,
etwas über zwei Wochen später, dann sind das genau die zehn Werktage Entwicklungszeit, die verloren gegangen sind. Ja, das heißt, die Entwicklerin bei SAP und deutsche Telekom haben hier,
es geschafft, dass nicht noch weiter zu verzögern das Projekt. Ähm insofern denke ich, dass hier eine.
Natürlich ist in Zeiten der Panämie sind zwei Wochen auch oder je nachde können auch drei Wochen sein, je nachdem, wie man zählt, ne, dann zweieinhalb. Das ist keine kurze Zeit. Nur ich würde die halt gerne,
einen in ein Verhältnis setzen, weil ja behauptet wurde und das ist ja auch der andere Punkt, der noch gemacht werden muss. Das,
unter die App früher da gewesen wäre und das ist ja einfach nicht der Fall, denn,
sie wäre nicht funktionsfähig gewesen, hätte die Bundesregierung auf den zentralen Ansatz gepocht, dann hätte sie nun eine nicht funktionale App, wenn überhaupt,
siehe Frankreich.
Der hat uns heute noch einen höherer äh einen Link geschickt zur da war ähm ich habe den mein französisch ist ja,
ähm etwas eingerostet, aber da ist, glaube ich, immer noch von so sechsstelligen Nutzerinnenzahlen, die Rede. Und Deutschland hat ja jetzt schon irgendwie mehrere Millionen äh ähm,
angegeben.
Ne, sodass man da also den die äh die die französische App nicht als besonderes Beispiel nehmen kann und der hier ja auch immer öfter erwähnte oder öfters schon erwähnte.
Kubi, hat mir gerade noch auf Twitter äh den Hinweis nochmal gezeigt, dass in Österreich sie ihre App äh.
Nee, das ist Norwegen. Österreich hast du gesagt.
Oh, nee, Entschuldigung, äh, Verzeihung. Natürlich, Norwegen. Äh danke, danke, bei der wäre aber jetzt was gewesen. Ne, in Norwegen natürlich, die müssen diese App ähm.
Nach einer äh Prüfung durch die Datenschutzaufsichtsbehörde ähm.
Beenden. Ja, die müssen alle bisher erfassen, da löschen. Also die Sasta.
Haben sie auch schon getan, genau.
Ja
Ja, also das, das ist halt eigentlich das ist eigentlich das, was wir auch vorhergesagt haben. Also.
Diese ganzen Lösungen, die ohnehin nur bekloppte Insellösungen sind und die also selbst wenn da was funktioniert hätte.
Es kann einfach nicht sein, dass wir mindestens in Europa und im Prinzip auch weltweit nicht ein einheitliches System haben. Und
es ist einfach klar, welches System das sein wird,
so. Und äh Frankreich und Ungarn, die glaube ich noch so den letzten in der Europäischen Union sind
werden da irgendwie klein beigeben äh müssen. Frankreich wahrscheinlich als erstes, das kann nicht mehr so weit weg sein. Ungarn ist halt nochmal ein anderes Problem,
So und dann,
wird's auch Skandinavien äh erreichen, et cetera, also auch im Baltikum, gibt's ähnliche Bewegungen, also litausche App ist da äh die auch einen anderen Weg gehen, wollte es da irgendwie auch durch.
Also Tim ist ganz klar die App, die App geht jetzt viral.
Sowas.
Das ist ja auch etwas, das wissen wir vielleicht gar nicht, das haben wir hier in der Sendung schon öfter besprochen, ähm aber an dieser Stelle möchte ich nochmal ganz kurz auf den ähm Jan Fleischhauer aufmerksam machen.
Dein Freund.
Ich hatte ja hier in der Sendung dann auch ausführlich korrigiert, was seine falsch darstellung im Fokus angeht.
Ähm eine direkte Reaktion blieb aus, aber er hat dann ähm vor ein paar Tagen einen Tweet von Alice Weidel, der AfD, welche Rolle hat ja nicht bei der AfD.
Sei ja egal, ne?
Ich glaube Fraktionschefin ist sehr.
So, also Alice Weidel, AfD. Ähm.
Hat einen Tweet abgesetzt, dieser Tweet von Alice Weidel lautet. Corona App,
sinnlos und gefährlich. Wir brauchen kein wir wollen und brauchen keine vorgeschobene Überwachung, ja? Also die geben jetzt volles von Aluhut, ne? Wie ähm nur wenige,
Institutionen in Deutschland es sich in dieser Lage trauen, ja? Mit so einer auf so einer dann doch sehr dünnen ähm Faktenbasis zu argumentieren, aber das ist jetzt für die AfD nie ein Problem. Jan Fleischschauer verbreitet das mit dem Kommentar.
Der Chaos Computerclub hat eine neue Vorsitzende. Ein wichtiger Schritt zur Sichtbarmachung von Frauen, auch in der Nerdwelt.
Ja, also das ist halt die, das Niveau dieses Menschen in der Auseinandersetzung, mit diesem Thema und ich glaube, dass.
Braucht man, also es ist, das ist so erbärmlich, da spare ich mir jeden Kommentar. Ähm auch, dass er meine Korrekturen und richtig Stellungen zu sein, falsch Behauptungen nicht.
In richtig Stellung hat Münden lassen da muss man eben alles selber machen, dann habe ich gestern dann noch ein Livestream von Chip und Fokus mitgemacht, zu dem ich eingeladen wurde,
Und dann habe ich gedacht, naja, okay, dann mache ich mal was mit dem Fokus und.
Habe dann da die Gelegenheit genutzt, an verschiedenen Stellen darauf hinzuweisen, welche Falschbehauptungen eben im,
im Fokus verbreitet werden und von wem, zu einer Kommentare von den Moderatoren so.
Wahrgenommen. In der FAZ habe ich das übrigens auch gemacht. Die FAZ hat mich auch zu der App interviewt und gefragt, das war so ein Video-Interview. Da habe ich auch gesagt, diese, auch wenn das
in ihre, auch wenn das in der FAZ von einigen Autoren falsch behauptet wird. Den Teil haben wir rausgeschnitten. Aus dem Video.
Ja, das hat aber Tim, das musst du so sehen. Das hat Redaktionell einfach nicht gepasst, ne? Das Video musste ein bisschen kürzer sein und so, ne? Wir haben uns ja auch nur auf die wichtigen Punkte kurz und knackig konzentriert und so, ne?
Na ja, so ist das. Ähm Open Source, müssen wir auch nochmal drüber sprechen, oder?
Äh klar, immer.
Die App ist Open Fours, auch das äh ausführlich äh in dem UKW besprochen, hier mit äh welche Lizenz und so. Ähm.
Jetzt ist es so, dass der,
Google Apple teil, nämlich das Senden und Empfang dieser Biekens und auch die Speicherung nicht. Ähm quell offen ist.
Und jetzt ist natürlich den die Frage wie bewerte wir das, dass das nicht Open Source ist. Da gibt's zwei
Probleme bei, dass dieser Teil nicht open Source ist. Das eine ist dieser ganze äh Vertrauen, transparent, Security Teil
ja, können wir draufgucken, dass es auch das tut, was es tut. Und das Zweite ist, ähm.
Open Source hat ja den Vorteil, dass unsere ähm französischen
Schwestern und Brüder. Wenn sie dann mit ihrer App jetzt äh vollständig gescheitert sind, zumindest den Quellcode von unserer äh implementierung
problemlos benutzen können. Sie haben dann noch das Heavy Lifting des Meldewesens vor sich, aber sie können so etwas da können sie von uns
äh profitieren.
Müssen nur ihrem äh äh beliebtesten und größten Staatsfranzösischen Staatskonzern irgendwie beibringen, dass das jetzt irgendwie SAP-Code ist, der hier zum Einsatz kommt.
Ja, aber also ich äh ne, gucken wir mal. So, jetzt ähm.
So, das ist der, der Vorteil von Open Source. Das ist auch andere verwenden können. Transparenz und das können auch andere verwenden. Den Transparenzaspekt, also es gibt jetzt dann auch einige, die sich melden und sagen, ja Google und Apple haben wir aber hier jetzt eine Hintertür und das ist jetzt alles die Corona Überwachung,
Das halte ich für eine, sage ich mal, ein äh Problem,
wirklich ganz, ganz stark untergeordneter äh Priorität, weil die hätten sich genauso gut für einen zentralen Ansatz entscheiden können und die,
könnten auch ohne, jetzt gut, der Witz, auch oder eine Schwachstelle in diesem Ex-Forscher-Notification Framework, könnten sie, weil sie nun mal diese Betriebssysteme kontrollieren, trotzdem in alles einblicken. Ja, das heißt, ähm.
Die Sorge, dass Apple und Google hier jetzt irgendwie anderhändet, eine Backdore reingebaut haben, die ist nicht begründet, weil sie die nicht bräuchten,
Das hatte ich hier auch schon mal gesagt. Wir haben die äh nicht schöne,
und nicht wünschenswerte, aber die nun mal nicht zu diskutieren, der Reiher Realität, dass wir diesen Betriebssystem herstellen dann vertrauen müssen, wenn wir das iOS benutzen und ein Google äh Android mit mit
mit Play Services. Das ist nun mal leider so. Ähm für den Security-Aspekt, da wäre es gut, wenn das wird und
richtig problematisch wird's aber eben in der Weiternutzung, denn es melden sich nun die Leute, die ihre von Google befreiten, Telefone benutzen, also beispielsweise Linage OS, mit einem da dran, ja,
die können diese App jetzt nicht benutzen, weil die eben auf die Play Services aufsetzt und diese PlayService sind eben bei den Google freien Geräten nicht dabei und die können also jetzt diese App nicht,
verwenden. Und das gleiche trifft zu äh für bestimmte Geräte, aufgrund dieser ähm.
Der Auslöser dafür sind ja diese ähm Exportrestriktionen von dem verrückten Orangen
äh gegen der ja unbedingten Handelskrieg mit China anzählen möchte. Da hat aber immerhin jetzt schon gesagt, okay, wir implementieren das jetzt einfach auch, unseren Teil dieser,
äh dieser Sache. Aber auch musstet jetzt eben irgendwie selber basteln, ne? Das ist auch zu beklagen. Also.
Ähm es wäre sinnvoll und notwendig hier durch quelloffenheit.
Für die Transparenz zu sorgen. Und vor allem für die.
Interoperabilität mit anderen Systemen. Das, das sehe ich hier am Ende, als das schwerwiegendere Problem. Ähm ich würde noch vorsichtig dazu sagen,
also es gab ja auch irgendwelche Spezialistinnen, Expertinnen irgendwie, ich habe gehört, dass,
DE, die haben die die Corona-App aus dem aus, von Gitup, irgendwie kompliziert und zum Download angeboten, haben gesagt, bei uns kriegen sie Corona App schon heute,
ja, die funktioniert aber nicht, weil die eben nicht äh weil ihr jetzt quasi von einer von einer Anbieterin ist, die,
die auf dieses Framework gar nicht zugreifen darf. Also hier arbeitet dann und spätestens da gehen dann eben die Sicherheit des Betriebssystemes,
die der Anspruch der Nutzerinnen auf Freiheit dessen, was sie mit dem Gerät machen. Auf einmal gegeneinander,
Und das ist immer schwierig, abzuwägen. Ähm
ich will da jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, äh aber äh vielleicht sollte das klassische Beispiel ist, äh es gibt relativ wenig Schadsoftware fürs iPhone und das liegt primär daran, dass das Ganze Ding äh
Code Signing verwendet, also jede App, die das iPhone ausführt, muss von Apple für die Verwendung auf diesem iPhone freigegeben worden sein. Das haben sie so gemacht, damit,
sie Raubkopien, damit es keine Raubkopien von App Store.
Geben kann und einer der Nebeneffekte ist eben, dass es auch wenig Schadsoftware gibt und genauso ist das bei diesen restriktion,
restringierten Zugriff auf diese, dass sie eben sagen, okay, wir lassen eine Epro Land zu und das machen wir spezifisch und die prüfen wir
Die Folge dessen ist das jetzt nicht jeder irgendwie hingehen kann und sich auch noch eine baut
Und da stehen diese Schutzziele oder diese Nutzeransprüche eben leider auch äh entgegen. Ich hoffe, dass Google,
es irgendwie ermöglicht, der der wirklich google freien Open Source Community eben auch dieses zu verwenden.
Also ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob eigentlich aus äh das, was im Play Services enthalten ist, überhaupt irgendwas, Open-Source ist oder ist das komplett geschlossen? Weißt du das.
Ich kann nicht sagen, ob das äh hat und aber es ist auf jeden Fall propreitär.
Sonst würden die Leute ja einfach sagen, alles klar, wir nehmen die, wir bauen uns die Play Service auch nochmal aus dem Source oder so, aber da bin ich, da bin ich nicht im Detail drin.
Es ist zumindest vorstellbar, dass dieser Teil, der ja letzten Endes was mit Bluetooth und Networking und so weiter zu tun hat. Vielleicht auch
in dem nächsten Android Release tatsächlich ins Betriebssystem wandert und dann ja auch automatisch Open Source wäre, dass sie das in diese Playservices reingebaut haben, das ist ja einfach nur dem Umstand geschuldet
dass man das schnell ausliefern wollte und dass das halt derzeit derjenige Weg ist, über die man es am schnellsten ausliefern kann. Na ja.
Ja, aber diese ganze Open Source Sache also bei Apple wurde natürlich dann auch gleich gefordert, aber wie du schon richtig gesagt hast.
Es würde halt nichts beweisen. Also da könnt ihr jetzt irgendein Source Code vorgelegt werden, dann machst du halt irgendwas da drunter oder daneben oder in einem ganz anderen Framework und.
Wie auch immer, wenn so eine Aushorchung in irgendeiner Form ein Ziel, dieser Unternehmen wäre, was ich wirklich, ehrlich gesagt, nicht glaube, ja.
Da können sie es auf jeden Fall machen.
Dann dann hätten sie das schon immer machen können, da brauchen sie auch diese Chorona Warn-App nicht für.
Also da ist schon alles da, ja und äh diese dieses dieses Kontaktdrasing fügt dem nichts hinzu, mit dem sie,
irgendwie groß wochern können. Was, was für eine Information soll daraus gewonnen werden.
Ja, absolut und ähm da gibt's dann natürlich, also da gibt's dann wirklich da kommen, dann bestimmte,
Fundamentalistin und Fundamentalistinnen zu Wort, bei denen man sich schon dann auch fragt
Warum die jetzt ausgerechnet über Geräte reden, die sehr offensichtlich selber noch nicht mal haben können bei ihrem bei ihrem Schutzniveau. Aber wie gesagt, das mit dem freien
äh dass dass die freien Androids jetzt nicht in der Lage sind, das zu nutzen, ist inakzeptabel, muss geklärt werden.
Ist aber ein lösbares Problem. Also ich meine in dem Moment, wo es wusste, solide Open Source äh Leibrie gibt die dasselbe macht und anbietet und äh dann das CBA-Team auch überzeugt werden kann, dass das etwas ist, worauf man auch basieren kann,
dann wäre es der durchaus vorstellbar. Aber ich erwarte auch, dass dieses Fremdwerk sich noch schnell weiterentwickeln wird. Von daher ist es noch nicht so final.
Wir haben schon darüber gesprochen, ähm die App hat eine Fehlerquote, ja hat sie ähm die negativen Konsequenzen sind.
Verhältnismäßig gering, hast ein paar Ruhe und dann Test ähm es gab schon schlimmere negative Konsequenzen.
Für Menschen,
äh die bestimmte Apps äh installiert haben. Und äh zu der Grundsicherheit, also jetzt überhaupt auch Überlegung, Schwachstellen und so weiter, ne
möchte ich nochmal betonen durch diesen dezentralen Ansatz und durch die Datensparsamkeit wird eben der größere Teil des Risikos minimiert. Und das ist
das Entscheidende bei IT-Sicherheit zu sagen, wenn etwas schiefgeht,
dann muss der Schaden minimiert werden, ja? Und das war zum Beispiel ist genau die Maßgabe auch von
dieser ähm Verbesserung in den äh in den Datenbank Zugriffsrechten, die da eingebracht wurde von verschiedenen, unter anderem Alverfreude, der es halt eingebracht hat, einen Tag zu spät, also
schon andere eingebracht hat, also auch egal, die uns beide einen validen Punkt gemacht, der nämlich darin besteht, dass man immer bei jedem Zugriff bei allem, was man tut, den minimal.
Die das minimale Schadenspotential macht. Und das tut diese App nun mal durch diesen dezentralen Ansatz und deswegen sind alle Schwachstellen, die da noch drinnen sein könnten oder so so
wie möglich in ihrem Schadenspotential minimiert und das war auch der Grund, warum wir uns da so für eingesetzt haben. Ähm.
Jetzt gab es noch, was ich sehr spannend fand. Also das war wirklich, weil ich kann es nicht anders. Ich kann dich anders als das hier zu behandeln. Ähm weil das so kurios war.
Auf heiße Online geht am Freitagabend eine Meldung online,
in der der TÜV sich in relativ vollmundigen Worten über die Chorona Warn-App.
Echoffiert,
Und in dem und sagt irgendwie, das ist sicher und das ist noch gar nicht alles geprüft und die ist überhaupt nicht Produktreif und äh und die Tanz sind unsicher und, und, und, und. Ja?
Und ich dachte mir so, äh das kann nicht sein. Und der Grund, warum das nicht sein kann, ist.
Ganz einfacher. Der TÜV gibt in diesem.
Ähm Bericht an, dass er mit der, mit dem BSI zusammenarbeitend, ein,
äh Security-Check oder Review von mehreren Teilen der Applikation vorgenommen hat. Beklagt sich aber zum Beispiel auch, dass sie nicht alle geprüft worden sein.
So, was ist, was ist daran, äh, warum sage ich, da kann was nicht stimmen. Nun, ich bin ja selber in dieser Branche tätig und ich weiß, wenn du den Auftrag für ein Security-Review hast, insbesondere vom BSI, da hast du mit dem BSI eine.
Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung, nämlich ein NDA und das bedeutet, sämtliche Geheimnisse, die du in diesem Zusammenhang in Erfahrung bringst. Äh.
Darfst du nicht dritten verraten und die Vereine in den Vereinbarungen mit dem BSI ist halt eben auch so, ne, wenn du eine Schwachstelle findest, musst du sie dem BSI melden. Und das BSI entscheidet wieder mit zu verfahren, ist insbesondere in diesem Fall, wo das BSI ja im Prinzip,
Arbeit von einem von anderen irgendwie da, prüft und koordiniert.
Insofern es war mir unerklärlich, wie der dir Kretschmer vom TÜV IT mit heiße Online über Details.
Seiner Arbeit für das BSI spricht. Und.
Will jetzt, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das BSI.
Die deutsche Telekom oder SAP, das besonders witzig oder unterhaltsam fanden, wenn einer ihrer äh vertrauten.
Mit äh Streiter,
Äh nun mit vermeintlichen interner in die Öffentlichkeit geht, insbesondere dann auch noch Schwachstellen beklagt die, wenn man dann mal in den Quelltext auf Git Up schaut, schon längst weg sind.
Ja, also auch da wieder eine Reise in die Vergangenheit. Der TÜV hat da offenbar eine äh Schwachstelle gemeldet, was
zu zu geringe Entropie der Tanz angeht und wenn du dann jetzt später in den Code guckst, dann siehst du, die sind jetzt länger und dat auch schon irgendwie seit Wochen. Ähm,
jetzt muss man dazu sagen, der TÜV hat ähm sich außerdem darüber beschwert, dass diese App Open Source sei.
Und sagt, dadurch, dass die App Source ist.
Ähm konnten die andere auch da reingucken und standen jetzt in Konkurrenz zu meinen Mitarbeitern. Ja sicher,
dass die Idee von Obst, was das andere auch reingucken. Und die haben sogar Sachen gemeldet und äh die die
vielleicht die TÜV-Mitarbeiterin nicht gesehen haben, ne? Das ist das Spiel. Die Idee von Transparenz und Öffentlichkeit. Und er hat sich dann auch noch irgendwie vollmundig gegen dieses Haus gewendet und man hat, also ich habe wirklich mich gefragt, was hat diesen
man geritten, wenn der wieder nüchtern wird, muss hindert unglaublich leidtun. Und was passiert, keine zwölf Stunden
knallrote, große DPA-Meldung. TÜV. Die Corona Warleb ist
beste seid geschnitten, Brot. Ich habe hier keine Lücken gesehen, das ist unglaublich, ne, was hier passiert und ähm erstaunlich, was was hier alles passiert ist. Ich,
und das war, äh, das war halt eben Samstagmorgen. Also, ich gehe, er hat noch ich sehe gerade, äh er hat noch äh dann auch dadrunter kommentiert, äh du schickst dir gerade den L.
Zusammenarbeit zwischen SAP, Telekom, den BSI äh meine Bedenken von damals sind relativiert und Kritik steht mir nicht zu.
Also ich möchte jetzt TÜV IT ist nicht ganz so klein, ne?
Dass die durchaus den ein oder anderen Auftrag,
vielleicht von, SHP, BSI oder Telekom hatten in der Vergangenheit und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie auch Wert darauf legen in der Zukunft, noch welche zu.
Als der als diesen Kommentar und dann ist der Ticket geschrieben hat, da hat ihm wahrscheinlich das Ohr von den letzten Telefonaten noch geblutet.
Also ich denke, ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich, noch nicht mal, dass dem, dass den irgendjemand etwas sagen musste.
Weil also dass den irgendjemand zu sau machen musste, weil als der Artikel online gegangen ist, muss der äh muss dem das Herz in die Hose gerutscht sein. Ähm,
na? Und das ist jetzt, ich sage das jetzt wirklich all das, sage ich jetzt vor dem Hintergrund dessen, was in dieser Branche üblich ist. Und in dieser Branche üblich ist, Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung, an die man sich hält. Und was sicherlich unüblich ist,
als Beauftragter Auditor, Ergebnisse eines in der Öffentlichkeit zu diskutieren, noch dazu den Eindruck zu erwecken, dass diese Schwachstellen vielleicht nicht,
ähm ähm behoben sein. Ja, das ist alles sehr ähm sehr sehr überraschend,
ähm entsprechend hat er dann ja auch offenbar mit ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz großen Schuhen äh versucht, dieses Feuer wieder auszutreten und äh wenn ich das jetzt bewerte, tue ich das wirklich vor dem Hintergrund der ökonomischen Interessen des Hilfs, weil das war
mit Sicherheit, das hat wirklich keinen guten Blick auf keinen Blick auf das Unternehmen geworfen. Ähm es macht nämlich ein, also,
ich würde mal so sagen, was ist so ein NDA? Das kannst du in deiner Karriere nur einmal brechen.
Und da muss ich dann schon lohnen, ne? Und was er da von dieser App erzählt hat, dafür hat sich das halt nicht gelohnt, insofern ähm
er hat hat es mich dann nicht überrascht, dass er diesen Eindruck korrigierte, er sagt außerdem damals und das deutet ja in seinem Kommentar so ein bisschen darauf hin.
Ähm das unter Umständen dieses Telefonat oder diese Meldung oder was auch immer er da der heiße Online-Redaktion erzählt hat.
Schon etwas in der Vergangenheit liegt. Das deute ich da jetzt mal so draus, ja? Und da würde ich vermuten, dass ähm das.
Vielleicht äh von der Seiten der Redaktion bei Heise online vielleicht noch Bemühungen gab, ähm,
SAP, Deutsche Telekom, BSI, vielleicht zu erreichen und vielleicht eine Stellungnahme zu bekommen oder so. Und dann haben sie die vielleicht nicht bekommen oder er später bekommen, äh insofern, ja, das wird dem Herrn Kretschmer auf jeden Fall.
Leid getan habe, fand ich auf jeden Fall unterhaltsam.
Es war ja auch ein inhaltlich, was ja auch dünne. Also es war ja jetzt nicht nur, dass da jetzt was rausgekommen ist und irgendwelche Geheimhaltungs äh Vereinbarungen gebrochen sind. Das, was da moniert wurde, war wirklich.
Unsinn. Also da da wurde von einem ominösen Algorithmus gesprochen und ich habe mir dann ins Haus angeschaut, es handelt sich dabei einfach um die Zufallszahl.
Also.
Ja, das ich glaube, es ging ihnen darum, um die Länge, ne, also er hat die Länge dieser Tannen äh bemängelt und ähm also ich glaube, dass Angriffsszenario wäre gewesen, du hast jetzt eine eine siebenstellige Tannen,
und dann ich glaub die Zeichen, Anzeige, die dazugelassen sind sie zu im Bereich einunddreißig,
müsste ich nochmal genau schauen, aber jetzt hast du halt einunddreißig hoch sieben und du gehst gegen diesen Vercation Server, da könntest du natürlich einen selbst implementierten Brutblut Brutforcangriff machen, auf diese Tanz, aber
ähm das habe ich dann auch an dem Abend, glaube ich, noch getwittert, weißt du, bevor ich ähm einunddreißig Uhr sieben oder jetzt in der neuen einunddreißig hoch neun Brutforce,
da rufe ich doch schon lieber einfach bei der, bei der Hotline an. Also, also es ist ja nicht so, als wird ein Angreifer unbedingt den Weg des höchsten Widerstandes für sich aus.
Ja und auch hier ist der Angriff, ja, also da wird ja nichts groß angegriffen sollen, man kauft sich quasi nur den Zugang zu veröffentlichen und auch das, also das.
Ich möchte, dass vor allen Dingen jetzt hier gar nicht so äh kritisieren, dass wir schon blöd gewesen, wenn du jetzt in der Lage gewesen wärst, ähm oder jeder Angriff, der es ermöglicht, ohne Niverifizierten.
Äh oder ein Verifiziertes, positives Testergebnis, eine Meldung zu veranlassen, ist ein großes, ist ein Problem für diese Infrastruktur und muss,
äh muss beseitigt werden und dieses Fining hatte der TÜV jetzt hier und diesem Feind wurde begegnet. Er hat sich dann halt nur danach noch in der Öffentlichkeit darüber beschwert, dass es nicht.
Ja, aber es ist, es bleibt wirklich pur-akademisch, weil klar kannst du da irgendwas Blut forsten, aber es funktioniert auch nur, wenn genau in dem Moment so eine Tarn auch erzeugt wurde und vorliegt. Weil die ja nicht sozusagen nur.
Sind immer nur eine Stunde gültig, wenn du ja, also.
Genau, also es ist einfach Quatsch. Also es ist äh.
Ja, ich würde nicht sagen, Quatsch, aber ist also ist auf jeden Fall Quatsch, sich darüber ähm stellt sich zu freuen, dass man den Beitrag geleistet hat, hier die Entropie der Tanz zu erhöhen.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja
Okay, haben wir jetzt auch lange genug äh ich ich sage nur, das es beschäftigt mich wirklich einfach nur, weil ich dachte so, oh mein Gott. So TÜV, verkaufen, verkauft, nächsten Verein, hast du keine Aktien dann? Okay, alles klar.
Ähm okay, dann gab es äh auf Twitter, einige Leute, die sich beschwert haben.
In der Pressekonferenz, äh dass dort äh bei der Vorstellung der Chorona Warn-App nicht im gedankt wurde,
auf Twitter. Wenigstens mal dem CCC danken, der jetzt hier über Monate, die Debatte begleitet hat und so. Ähm.
Ich sage mal vorsichtig ich habe an einigen Stellen
die vorsichtige Warnung davor ein Klicken lassen, uns für diese App zu vereinen haben. Und ähm, dass da der Community Gedanke wurde, die Open Source,
draufgeschaut hat und Verbesserungen eingebracht hat das ist schon genau richtig so. Das finde ich da wurde den richtigen Gedank. Alles andere ist 'ne politische Auseinandersetzung und da muss auch nicht gedankt werden.
Ist ja auch nicht so, dass der Zitze jetzt hier die einzige Organisation gewesen wäre, also dieser offene Brief, der äh an die Bundesregierung ging. Der war ja dann.
Ja, ja, Kampf kam von mehreren, ich bezweifle, dass der offene Brief jetzt wirklich das ausschlaggebende war, aber ich wollte das nur kurz sagen, dass sich das
dass sich das ist auch unüblich wäre sich hier zu bedanken, ne? Wenn die, wenn ihr ein Gesetz verabschiedet, ist das ja auch nicht danke an die Opposition, für die, für die guten Ideen.
Kurze Rolle des CC nochmal, wir haben ja eben vor
mehr als zwei Monaten die Prüfsteine definiert. Wir haben dann gesagt, okay, wir werden vor etwas warnen, was diesen Prüfstein scheitert und ähm wir,
sehen uns in dieser Debatte ihnen beraten, dann kontrollierende Rolle
Ähm SAP und deutsche Telekom, auch das hatte ich hier glaube ich erwähnt, haben eben sich auch selber nach diesem Prüfstein geprüft. Das hatten wir nämlich auch gesagt, so wir machen das nicht. Muss man ja auch mal sagen, das ist ein Millionenprojekt. Soll ich da jetzt auch noch ehrenamtlich mich hinsetzen und äh und den
den irgendwie eine Zertifizierung ausstellen. Das machen wir nämlich auch nicht
ja? Und ähm wir haben gefordert die App muss Quell offen sein und da gab's jetzt die Verbesserungsvorschläge und das ist doch alles
sehr schön. Grundsätzlich, wir haben unsere Bedenken geäußert, als wir welche hatten. Ähm wir.
Empfehlen aus grundsätzlichen Erwägungen nie irgendetwas, weil wir wissen, dass es viele von sich von uns wünschen.
Und uns vereinnahmen möchten, dafür stehen wir nicht zur Verfügung und in dem Kontext sich eben auch das, das ist hier jetzt keine großartige Erwähnung des CC oder was weiß ich, äh,
dieser App gab und das ist auch genauso richtig gelaufen. Da kann man ja auch einfach mal äh.
Ne, Politik ist, läuft mal gut, ne? Mal verlierst du, mal gewinnen, die anderen und ähm wenn dann mal von dieser Regel wichen wird, dann kann man sich auch einfach so darüber freuen.
Kommen wir zu den allseits beliebten Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Kurzmeldungen.
Die immer nicht so kurz sind. Die.
Eine eine Meldung von weiß, dot com, die denke ich auch,
Also die wir auch nochmal in Zukunft öfter diskutieren werden, aber wir ich fahre jetzt hier mal kurz in einer kurzen zusammen. Und zwar gab es offenbar ein notorischen.
Belästiger auf Facebook, der über mehrere Jahre junge Mädchen irgendwie angemacht hat, belästigt hat
irgendwie versucht hat Fotos von ihnen zu erpressen und irgendwie sie mit Mord und Vergewaltigung zu bedrohen, also irgendwelche eine ganz schräge Scheiße, ja? Und.
Das hat er offenbar über Jahre gemacht, in ganz ekelhaften äh ganz ekelhafter Art und Weise. Und das war Facebook hat das
erkannt und Facebook war das ein Dorn im Auge und dem äh das Facebook hat dann auch das FBI eingeschaltet und mit denen zusammenzuarbeiten, um diesen Menschen,
das Handwerk zu legen. So, was hat er gemacht, um es zu erschweren, dass man ihnen detektiert, der hat einfach über
den Anonymisierungsdienst Tor auf Facebook zugegriffen. Jetzt muss ich mal sagen, welcher Handlungsoptionen,
hatte Facebook an dieser Stelle. Ähm sie hätten beispielsweise,
auch einfach sagen können, okay, wir blockieren Tor. Das haben sie nicht getan, das wäre problemlos möglich gewesen, das haben sie nicht getan. Aus verschiedenen Gründen. Erstens, weil sie sagen, nee, der anonymisierte Zugriff auf unsere Systeme muss ja möglich sein.
Ähm Facebook ist da kein, also ich will jetzt nicht genau Facebookrolle zu Tor diskutieren, das ist auch wieder kompliziert, sagen, was kurz da ohnehin die Leute sich dort anmelden,
und eigentlich unter kleinerem Zwang stehen, ist natürlich das Nutzen von Facebook, über Tor, äh ein.
Eine ähm marginal ein maginalinteresse, ähm,
da wird man jetzt nicht mehr viel Schutz bekommen, aber immerhin, sie haben sich nicht entschieden, den anonymisierten Zugang auf ihre Dienste zu verhindern
Der Grund, warum sie sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht getan haben, ist, dass ihr konkretes Ziel war, diesen Menschen der Strafverfolgung zuzuführen. Und da hatte Facebook offenbar sehr große Motivation zu, denn.
Selbst mit dem FBI haben sie's nicht geschafft, diesen Bastar Herr Nandes zu enttarnen und haben dann.
Hat Facebook quasi ein Experte gekauft oder entwickeln lassen für,
Tales, das Betriebssystem, was der ähm.
Was dieser äh Typ benutzt hat. Tales ist wie, oh, ich kann das Wort immer nicht auf Deutsch aussprechen. Ähm.
Dass äh das Inkorgnito Live-System mit Amnesie heißt das auf Deutsch. Auf Deutsch kann ich's sagen. Ähm ein ein man startet das im Prinzip von einem
äh USB-Stick und äh es soll eigentlich allen Traffic immer durch Torruten und es hat
wenn man's nicht spezifisch nochmal eine verschlüsselte Patition anlegt, auch kein State. Das heißt, das Ding merkt sich nichts, ne? Das das macht alles im im,
Ramm und wenn du dann irgendwie den den Stick rausziehst, ist auf dem Computer nichts zurückgeblieben und in der Standardkonfiguration auch in den Tails nichts zurückgeblieben. So.
Ähm relativ beliebt eben für so für den Sicherheitsbereich
äh indem man na sicher Dateien scheren muss sich ja recherchieren muss, keine äh keine Information über sich selbst zurücklassen muss. Es ist aber nicht mein präferiertes äh Anonymisierungssystem. Und zwar,
weil die Anonymisierung, das Tor-Routing bei Tales auf dem gleichen Betriebssystem stattfindet, auf der gleichen mit der kompletten anders Oberfläche dieses Betriebssystem ist. Und was ich auch in dem Vortrag mit Thorsten, wir beide,
Thorsten und ich betonen ist, du willst die anonymisierung, eigentlich auf einer anderen haben, damit dir niemand die Anonymisierung kaputt,
Das System, was das macht, äh nennt sich Hunix. Ähm wenn man das in virtuellen Maschinen betrachtet und ansonsten baust du die halt einfach einen eigenen Torruter,
quasi der transparent in Tor reinrutet, damit egal was auf deiner Arbeitsmaschine passiert, du unter keinen Umständen niemals ein IP-Paket außerhalb von Tor sendest, ja.
Ähm,
Jetzt hat der Typ halt Tales genutzt und Facebook hat äh offenbar irgendjemanden bei äh gefunden und damit beauftragt einen Explot zu entwickeln, der spezifisch auf Tales zugeschnitten ist.
Und dieser Explot diesen Export hat Facebook dann dem FBI über dritte Zukommen lassen.
Also Facebook hat dem FBI ein Exploice gesponsort.
Und die haben den äh dankend angenommen und haben dann eine Videodatei,
äh äh angefertigt, in der sich dieser Explodio verparkt, der Explod war in den Medienplayer, der bei Tales drin ist und der Explot war geeignet, diesen Medienplayer so zu übernehmen, dass der dann,
außerhalb von Tor, ein echtes IP-Paket sendet. Äh und zwar mit der IP-Adresse, die du versuchst, zu verschleiern. Und dann ist dann dieses Geschenk, ne, dann schickst du ein
IP irgendwohin und sagst, alles klar. Ist angekommen, der ist es jetzt beim Mobilfunk äh oder Netzwerkprovider herausfinden, wo der äh wo der sich aufhält und dann äh treten wir denn die Tür, eine Zähne da raus.
Das ist dann auch passiert. Und äh Junge, Junge. Also, was für eine Story
Also Facebook-Zeit für einen Explot auf den Open Source anonymisierungsbetriebssystem und schenkt in dem FBI und das FBI-Heck damit jemanden,
jetzt muss man natürlich sagen, diese Schwachstelle hatte jedes Tales
ähm mit anderen Worten genau das, was wir hier meinen, ne? Hier wurde eine Schwachstelle gefunden und dann zumindest geheim gehalten, bis sie ausgenutzt wurde und,
noch der Zug Zeit hier in privatwirtschaftliches Unternehmen, ne, wenn ich's jetzt mal den Begriff verwenden darf, eine Cyberwaffe für eine strafverfolgungsbehörde. Also.
Kannst du einschätzen, was das für eine Größenordnung ist, so finanziell? Ich meine, das ist ja schon ein ziemlicher ziemlicher Brocken, so ein so ein Explod.
Na ja, müsste ein Routexploid sein, damit du irgendwie überhaupt an die Netzwerk-Routing-Sachen drankommst. Andererseits in einem Medienplayer, das das überrascht mich jetzt nicht, weil ne äh
Medien zu passen, diese ganzen.
Äh diese ganzen ähm Kodex, die da zum Einsatz kommen, das ist, das ist, sind sehr viele, ne, so ein Medienplayer muss Unmengen an Codex unterstützen, diese Kodex wiederum werden so geschrieben, dass sie schnell sind,
Ja, also ne, das heißt äh die, die müssen ihre Aufgabe schnell ermöglichen und,
dann klingt es, scheint es mir so, dass sie wahrscheinlich irgendwo ein äh,
Buffer-Overflow in irgendeinem der Kodex gefunden haben, die dieser Medienplayer verwendet und dann noch äh von 'ne hatten
Preis, ihr habt jetzt sicherlich nicht bitte ich sein, vor allem, wenn in dem in dem Artikel, wird der Eindruck erweckt, dass sie den Tagetit.
In Auftrag gegeben haben und der nicht schon von irgendjemandem äh so,
quasi äh der den vielleicht eh schon in der Schublade liegen hatte. Kann sein, ne? Aber da wird der wird schon nicht günstig gewesen sein.
Also sechsstellig.
Würde ich jetzt auf jeden Fall sagen.
Okay, ne?
Noch dazu ist ja eine der immer doch sehr hervorgehobenen.
Ähm eines der immer halt sehr hervorgehobenen Schutzsysteme, die vielen Leuten empfohlen werden, die gerade im Journalismusbereich vielen ähm empfohlen werden und so.
Und obwohl Teil zu vielen Leuten empfohlen wird.
Es ist nicht mein präferiertes System, weil dieses so Torhuting auch auf der gleichen Büchse stattfindet und der Computer, der hat eine Netzwerkdose, die ist,
von dem Betriebssystem, mit dem ich da arbeite, zugreifbar,
so schaffst du es natürlich dann eben auch da irgendein IP-Paket woanders hinzuschicken. Wenn du gut bist und das da verteidigt sich Tails mit allen möglichen Mitteln gegen, aber offenbar hier,
nicht äh richtig. Und ja, insofern überrascht mich diese Explodien nicht. Interessant ist.
Dass sie hier spezifisch auch auf den Videoplayer gehen konnten, weil der Typ ja irgendwelche Videos von den von den,
ähm Menschen erpressen wollte. Und sie haben's im Zweifelsfall stelle ich mir jetzt Hypothetisiere ich. Sie konnten wahrscheinlich sehr einfach erkennen, dass der wieder einen Account angelegt hat bei Facebook.
Werden sie ja jedes Mal stilllegen, ne, aber es ging ja hier nicht darum, denen das Handwerk zu legen, sondern den der Strafverfolgung zuzuführen. Mit anderen Worten, ich gehe davon aus, Facebook hat dann einfach in Zusammenarbeit mit dem FBI mal geguckt, okay.
Was gibt's hier für neu angelegte Accounts von Leuten, die über Tor kommen? Dann beobachten wir die mal.
Aha, alles klar, der zeigt in seinen Messages und in seinem Suchverhalten das Verhalten der Zielperson, dann schlagen wir dem doch jetzt mal ein paar äh hübsche, junge Mädels vor. Einige davon sind unsere Fake-Accounts,
oder wahrscheinlich vielleicht alle,
und äh dann lassen wir uns mal äh brav von dem erpressen und äh sagen, ja, ja, okay, wir schicken dir ein Video. Und dann haben sie ihm das Video geschickt und dann hat er das geöffnet und abgespielt und dann kam das IP
und dann haben sie den Knast gebracht. Also es ist eine Zusammenarbeit, die äh hart ist. Also das äh das ist schon eine krasse Sache.
Und da fällt mir, da fehlen mir so ein bisschen die äh die Worte.
Dir fehlen die Worte zu.
Zur Einordnung, ja? Weil, weil wenn das jetzt jemand, ne, weißt du, dass die.
Die Wahrnehmung dessen, was sie da getan haben, wird natürlich jetzt dadurch gefärbt, dass sie es gegen ein jahrelangen Serientäter, der es cool fand, äh Kinder zu erpressen, getan haben, ne? Das äh,
Das ist natürlich eine eine Bewertung den Aspekte dann in die Bewertung mit einfließt.
Aber grundsätzlich ist das schon einfach Präzedenzfall und absoluter.
Ja eine gewisse Sprachlosigkeit.
Ja, weil man ja auch nicht weiß, wo.
Wo es sozusagen die Grenze, ja, wenn das FPI jetzt mit einem anderen Fall kommt, der nicht so einfach moralisch zu bewerten ist. Sage ich mal, ne und.
Sieht man auf jeden Fall was was möglich ist und was äh die Gefahren sind.
Ja und hätte fest, also Handlungsalternative, wenn Facebook jetzt gesagt hätte, okay, wir sperren anonymisierungsdienste, dann muss man natürlich auch echt sagen, dann hätten sie einen riesigen Kollateralschaden ange.
Ähm.
Angezerrt. Na? Und also, ich fänd's super, das können wir doch mal hier an äh unsere Kommentarschreiberinnen und Schreiber äh,
übergeben. Das scheint mir echt eine spannende,
ethische Diskussion zu sein, die so in nämlich dem weißer Ticket eben auch innerhalb von Facebook sehr kontrovers geführt wurde, man offenbar ne, hat weiß ja dann offenbar auch von einem.
Der Facebook-Mitarbeiter oder Mitarbeiterin diesen Hinweis bekommen.
Auch von Twitter haben wir was Neues, ja, Twitter hat jetzt so einen Testteil, dass sie die Leute, wenn wenn jetzt quasi etwas und einen Artikel verbreitet und der Twitter klein nicht den Eindruck hat, desto.
Ähm den Artikel gelesen hast, dass sie dich dann darauf hinweisen, sagen übrigens, du verbreitest hier gerade etwas, was du selber nicht gelesen hast, willst du nicht nochmal reingucken.
Interessante Idee, oder?
Ja, net hat. Also funktioniert, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, ähm auf welcher Basis das funktioniert.
Aber sie werden sicherlich getestet haben, bevor sie damit öffentlich gegangen sind. Sie bemühen sich zumindest. Ich weiß nicht, ob es viel helfen wird, aber.
Gibt auf jeden Fall ein Bienchen für für die Bemühung.
Ich find's interessant. Das testen sie in der Android-Version. Also nur bei Retreats ähm wo
ihr im Prinzip quasi nicht auch schon auf den verlinkten Artikel geklickt habt. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange das dauert bis Donald Trump äh das merkt.
Meinst du, muss ich jetzt die Dinger auch noch durchlesen, die er da die ganze Zeit raushaut?
Na, ich glaube, also das, was er da raushaut, das hat er sich ja auch angeguckt, das ist ja immer auch sehr kurz und von geringer Komplexität. Ähm.
Da, na ja
und wir haben eine, das wird jetzt auch wieder Thema, ein Thema, von dem man eigentlich dachte, dass das langsam vorbei ist, Fallsharing und Freifunk, ne? Da gibt's jetzt wieder ein ein Urteil äh vom Amtsgericht
Köln, Köster vom Amtsgericht Köln, der Richter heißt äh Eislerfunke. Da geht's in einer Auseinandersetzung,
eben über die Störerhaftung von Anbieterinnen von freien Netzwerken und da hatte ich ja eigentlich den Eindruck, dass dieser Teil jetzt,
inzwischen geklärt sei, äh mit der TMG Novelle, ja, wo nämlich gesagt wurde, es gibt ausdrücklich ähm,
das war das ausdrückliche Ziel, die Haftungsgefahr für Ausschluss in Anschlussinhaber auszuschließen. Und eigentlich dachte ich, nämlich dieses Thema, wer jetzt seit gut zwei Jahren erledigt, aber hier gibt's jetzt wieder ein, ein Urteil, wo eine.
Ich glaube irgendwie über siebzig Jahre alte Frau, die da in irgendwie mehr Generationenhaus die Eignerin des Telefonanschlusses ist zur Zahlung von zweitausend Euro an,
verurteilt wurde, weil sie da eben frei freies Netz betreibt. Und selber überhaupt gar keinen Computer hat. Also das scheint auch wieder wirklich so ein irrsinniges Fehlurteil zu sein, was da eingegangen ist und da haben wir eigentlich gedacht, dass wir sowas nicht mehr hätten.
Meine Oma klar und mit Freifunk deine oh ge.
Ja, unglaublich.
Ja, also nur nur, damit jetzt hier nicht alle denken, es gibt nur noch gute Nachrichten.
Ich glaube, diese Gefahr sieht keiner. Oder? Wir wissen's.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir auch mal ein bisschen durchschnaufen, was irgendwie Corona App und so weiter betrifft, glaube ich. Ähm.
Aber gut, das habe ich jetzt gesagt, ist wahrscheinlich nächste Woche schon wieder hinfällig. Mal gucken. Wird sicherlich noch spannend sein, dass äh weiter zu verfolgen. Aber gibt auch noch andere Themen.
Wir müssen ja noch ganz kurz sagen, ne? Den Epidemiolologischen Wert und nutzen und so weiter, dieser App äh haben wir uns nie angemaß beurteilen zu können.
Das ist ein großes Experiment und wir werden sehen, wie das dieses Experiment weitergeht. Wieso viele Experimente,
die wir hier machen. Hast du übrigens mitbekommen, dass jetzt der deutsche Impfstoff, ne, der kann am Menschen geprüft werden. Und ich würde ja vorschlagen, nein,
Entschuldigung, ich weiter nur nochmal einen Paco oder äh daran erinnern, dass wir das, weil sie schon noch Chip gechipt kriegen.
Euch kriegen wir schon noch gechipt.
Kriegen wir auch noch gechipt. Da wird echt Zeit. Also bei dem Attilerhelm, man wird's auf jeden Fall Zeit, dass der war langsam gechipt wird. Also der ist ja schon ganz wuschig.
Dem wurde übrigens irgend so ein komischer äh Telegramm-Kanal jetzt aufgemacht von habe ich heute Morgen auf Twitter gelesen.
Ja, habe ich auch gelesen.
Ja, so ist das. Ich sage mal, da sind natürlich auch diese Verschwörungstheoretikergruppen echt anfällig für für ähm.
Andere ja.
Angriffe, weil die ideologische Festigkeit der Leute zu prüfen oder ne, sage ich mal, oder die,
Wenn du, wenn du eine Verschwörung hast, ja? Und du möchtest die ideologische Festigkeit einer Kandidatin prüfen,
ja? Dann ist das im rationalen Bereich relativ kompliziert, das zu faken, ne? Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, du bist irgendwie,
Ne, was weiß ich. Du möchtest in den Geheim in den Geheimkreis, der äh Raketenwissenschaft,
aufgenommen werden, ne? Dann müsstest, müsstest du relativ viel über Raketen, Wissenschaft wissen, um die davon zu überzeugen, dass du ihrer würdig bist. Wenn du aber wenn du Verschwörungstheoretiker Zirkel zirka willst, ne, dann musst du ja einfach nur ungeachtet jeder,
Eisenhardt bei der Story bleiben, ja? Und wenn die dir dann sagen, wie bewertest du diese Veröffentlichung ähm was weiß ich.
In der ARD, da musst du einfach nur sagen, ah, das ist die Medien-Lügenpresse. Ja, und also es ist halt relativ einfach, dich da reinzusocialenieren,
weil du, weil du jetzt nicht mal relativ wenige Risiken hast, dich versehentlich zu verraten, solange du einfach nur dabei.
Ja du musst einfach nur mitschreien.
Also solange du das Risiko minimierst, dich versehentlich durch rationale Argumente zu verraten. Ähm hast du dein leichtes Spiel.
Ja. Einfach auch nochmal irgendwas abstruses selber noch erfinden. Am besten einfach Postion, äh Artikel reinpasten und sich total drüber aufregen.
Kommt richtig gut.
Was ist das?
Hier und überhaupt und da habt ihr diesen Twitter-Account schon gesehen, die haben jetzt wieder neue Kämpferelles angekündigt.
Jetzt ist das Twitter-Account Kim, Kim Trails vierundzwanzig.
Ich glaube, den, ich glaube, der folge ich auch, den immer so Flugzeuge, ne? Schöne Flugzeuge fotos dazu.
Ja, da wird war das was soll ich sag.
Von irgendwelchen Fässern am Flughafen und so weiter.
Ist nicht.
Piloten oder sowas? Ja, ich habe auf, ich kenne auf jeden Fall aus der Twitter-Account hin.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie er heißt, aber äh der der sagt dann immer durch, wenn wieder neue Flüge sind und ja, die haben sich dann auch äh haben sich dann auch entschuldigt, dass dann irgendwie nichts liefingen, Corona und so, ne.
Da konnte ja nicht geflogen werden.
Aber der Service wird bald wiederhergestellt. Ist mal ganz ganz mein Humor.
Ja, das war's für heute, würde ich sagen.
Okay? Das war's für heute. Mir bleibt nur noch kurz Manuela, Britta und Malte zu danken.
Alles klar, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, hört auch mal bei UKW rein und wie euch das interviewt gefallen hat und äh nächste Woche gibt's dann wieder mehr LNP und äh so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Und so weiter. Bis bald, tschüs.
Ciao ciao.
Tschüss Meros.
Keine Bock im Haus und es geht.